No, no starting screen.
I'm just in.
Just in.
In the game.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, dragons.
And also, people in Zentreya's chat.
Hello.
Kicking it like it's 2010.
Just straight in the game.
Yeah, just go right in.
Usually.
Alright.
Let me see.
Yay.
There's me.
I'm Mr. Bowman.
Welcome to Let's Play.
Okay, let's see if it's like... I'm trying to make sure it's not... I don't know if it's lagging on the game visual.
Oh, is it?
I can't tell.
Alright, I'm Mr. Bowman.
Because it's like a gun.
I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna see if I can turn off.
Oh, Zen, you can invite me whenever.
I don't know if I can show it.
Oh, Zen's too loud?
Okay, I'll turn Zen down a little.
Uh... Oh, yeah.
You're at 188 for some fucking reason.
I think... I think it's because the game is like kind of loud.
So sometimes I turn people up instead of turning the game down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I turned the game down today.
Advanced setting.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm just making sure.
Alright.
Beautiful.
We love that for me.
Alright.
Chat, let me know if everybody sounds good or not.
Yeah.
I'll get you guys in here in just a second.
Hello, hello, hello.
Testing, testing, testing.
Testing, testing.
One, two, three.
And also the games.
Oh, shit.
Thanks, Zen.
Yeah, Zen.
Maybe I wanna know if I sound okay on your screen stream.
Also, where's the training area?
I keep forgetting how... Okay, there it is.
You sound wonderful.
Alright.
So, guys, the gameplay volume, let me know.
So I'm Mr. Bowman.
Look at that.
Pew.
Oh, it's a training room so I can test the gameplay volume.
Yeah.
I'm doing that too.
Let's check it in.
Do you need us to up in here and troubleshoot?
Uh... No.
I'm good.
I think we're good.
I just have the occasional setters.
But, like, it happens very randomly so I don't know when it's gonna hit me.
Okay.
We'll leave you to it if you're all good-ish then.
Yeah?
I think so.
Yeah, I think so too.
Sounds good.
Thank you for help.
Yep.
Bye-bye.
Thank you very much.
Doki, where's the training room?
Um... Okay, so you look at your map, right?
Uh-huh.
Okay, we have to get out of the training room so I can...
Yeah, look at the map.
It's on the...
Right side.
So you see the...
Uh...
You see the camp area?
The camping thing?
Yeah.
That's the training area.
Okay.
I look.
Thank you.
Alright.
Guys, you wanna see my ult?
Give me a sec.
I can't...
It won't let me have my ult yet.
Let me get you guys in here.
Alright.
Trying to build up my ult.
Okay, I'm gonna accept Zen's invite real fast.
Is that volume good, chat?
Or do I need to turn the game up?
I don't know...
I don't know if my sound people are alive.
You should, like...
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so chat...
I can do this.
Watch this.
And then that marks everybody and...
Causes more damage for my team.
So...
Yeah, guys.
We had to...
We can talk about yesterday, right?
I don't know.
Can we wait?
Can we, Zen?
We can, okay.
Okay, so yesterday...
Yesterday, we played...
How many hours?
Six hours?
I don't know...
I just know...
Our first...
We had to...
So we were like...
Alright, guys.
You're supposed to unlock these characters...
And...
Beat these before today.
And then we're like...
Oh, that can't be that bad.
Six hours later...
We did.
We were like...
We had to go into the game...
Like...
Completely blind.
So we had to learn the game...
And everything.
And we were just like...
Yeah, we were learning the game.
And it was like...
Six hours later...
We beat the first boss.
We...
I had been awake at that point.
Like...
When I rejoined...
After...
After your stream...
When I rejoined...
Doki was like...
Are you okay?
Huh?
Yes, Zen?
Can you repeat that?
A lot of them do.
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah.
And then like...
A lot of the boss is like you.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Like every time...
And then...
Yeah, yeah.
That's what's...
Yeah, that's true.
Okay, so like...
You know how I'm an archer, right?
All the bosses were running straight at me.
The archer of the group.
Like...
I'm here in like two seconds.
I would be like...
Hey guys, I'm here.
And then the boss rushes towards me and fucking crushes me.
I was like...
Guys, I need a res.
I...
Oh yeah.
And then like...
And then we were like...
I'm glad she's tanking all the damage for us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just the tanker.
And then like...
We finished our first boss.
And then...
So...
For those who don't know, guys.
There are speed runners and like actual pro souls players that are playing this game.
And they're like...
Oh yeah, we have multiple save files where we can kill multiple bosses.
And then there's us with one save file with the first boss that we completed yesterday.
They were like which save file I saw we were like, looking at the channel like...
I believe in the U.S.
They were like which save file should we use?
And...
We were like...
What do you mean?
Which save file?
Oh, you're talking about people that are like been playing for a bit or so.
They're like for a week, casual?
And they're like, which poster we do?
And I was like, what do you mean?
Which boss?
We are still like the first one.
So like, so the event there's supposed to be three bosses, they've Some teams know what the three bosses are, we only know what the one boss is like.
So when we get past the, When we get past the first boss, it's all new to us.
We're gonna be like, alright, what do we do now?
It's okay.
This is winner's POV.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, yeah, don't worry.
We're the winner's POV, guys.
I played some practice games of the previous game earlier.
Look, slow and steady wins the race.
It's not about the speed.
Also, guys, we can't troll too much because apparently...
My reaction time has improved.
That's true, that's true.
Also, guys, we can't troll too much because we found out that if we die, we have to sit there and watch other people.
So we have to make it to the end.
Like, we don't want to sit and watch.
So we actually have to try really hard.
Don't worry.
We just don't die easy.
This is sweaty gamers.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we're gamers.
I feel like I don't remember a lot of yesterday because...
We just keep what we did last night an easy clap.
Exactly.
Honestly, our last run was so fucking good.
We had such good RNG.
We had really, really good RNG.
It was good, yeah.
That day, I woke up at 7 a.m.
to go out for the day.
And when we finished up, Doki, it was 6 a.m.
I ready up just in case.
So it's just...
I'm usually ready up, and then Zen will be like the final ready up.
Yeah, we just don't die.
Just don't die, guys.
It'd be fine.
Easy peasy.
Alright, bring Zen down.
Okay, I'll bring Zen down a little bit more.
Is audio balance good here, chat?
I don't know if audio balance is good.
You're not like this?
And also the game, too.
Let me know.
Chat.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
Um...
But yeah, no, I thought it was really fun so far.
I've been...
I think, for me, it's at the multiplayer is really fun.
Single player, I was not enjoying single player as much.
And it is more so...
When you were, like, playing the other...
Or the base game?
Yeah, when I...
No, when I was playing, no...
It's because you don't have your friends with you.
The Night Ring, single player.
Because it's like...
I don't know.
It's definitely a lot...
It's more difficult, for sure.
Even with its scaling.
And I feel like it's just more fun playing multiplayer.
Because if I'm going to play single player...
I think you just missed our voices.
If I'm just...
Yeah, that too.
If I'm...
I missed when I have, like, actual DPS.
Um...
But, like...
I feel like if I'm going to play single player, I'll just play Elden Ring.
The base game.
You know?
I feel like the Night Ring is more so suited for, like...
If you want to have, like, a...
RNG with your team type deal.
Oh yeah, guys.
Here's my ult.
Watch this.
Wait.
I just forgot to use my ult.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Boom.
My giant arrow.
Overall though, I think we got this on lock.
Yeah, I think so.
I think we're so, like...
We have to find the...
What is it called?
The flask enhancement places?
Because the five flasks really helped us out a lot.
I think the five flasks was really, really good.
Oh no, guys.
There is a Luna Snow in there, but she's weak as hell.
She's so...
She's, like, so squishy.
Does anybody...
Everybody know what they're playing?
Yeah.
Bowman.
I think that's just right now.
Ow.
I'm Bowman.
I'm gonna die in the training room.
But you can die in the training room?
You can...
You can animate this soldier guy and he will...
Oh, we gotta tune into the YouTube and Twitch stream.
Oh, we do?
Okay.
We got the what?
Wait, what?
Oh, wait.
Tune into the YouTube and Twitch stream.
Oh.
Oh, we have to watch it?
Okay.
Indeed.
Alright, guys.
Go check out the...
The YouTube...
The YouTube stream.
We actually need to get the link.
I...
Oh, yeah.
Hold on.
Let me find the link to it.
Oh, it's just like...
Oh, I guess they're just going through the rules and stuff, right?
Does anyone...
Do you guys have the link to it?
I think so.
I don't know where...
Oh, wait.
I see it.
Never mind.
Here we go, guys.
Ah, here.
I found it.
Yeah, I found it.
Okie dokie.
You got it.
Yeah.
That sound...
Oh, and then bring lime a little bit.
Oh, wait.
That's not the right one.
Sorry.
That video is private.
I'll just click the Twitch one.
Wait, why is that video private?
Is that not the right one?
Oh, it wasn't.
What?
Okay.
It's a private to me, too.
No, yet...
It's a...
It's a different embed.
That's weird.
No, you have to click on the actual YouTube link, not the embed.
Oh.
I'm just...
I mean, sorry, the embed.
You have to click on the embed, not the YouTube link.
Got you.
I swapped it around.
I'll just click the Twitch link.
That seems easier.
I guess they're like...
Wait, that's Jake from Overwatch.
What is he doing here?
Wait, he does stuff out...
He exists outside of Overwatch?
Today we learned.
Me when I exist.
So, do we re-broadcast the stream?
Is that what we're doing?
I don't think so.
They just said to watch the stream to see what's going on.
Yeah, we're just watching it.
Yeah, it doesn't say we have to...
I'll just sit in the hold then.
...broadcast it.
Oh my god, he's real.
I didn't know he was a Souls player.
I can't believe they actually, like, flew people out to the Worlds Between for this.
Wait, really?
Oh yeah, I'm gonna show chat the other characters.
Okay, guys.
Where is it?
Oh, album.
That just seems cool.
I feel like a lot of her damage potential probably comes from having characters with high damage potential.
Because, like, your mimic thing should be used after they use their high damage ults, I think.
Oh, the rewind time thing is so cool.
I like her rewind time feature.
Yeah, that's really cool.
So what I can do...
Yeah.
...is after you use your arrow, and then if Zen's using the main guy, the wild guy...
Either one of those.
If I use my rewind, then that hits again.
Oh, I didn't realize it was, like, all of us together.
I thought it was just your damage.
Mm-mm.
I was like, I'm showing them Revenant.
So, guys, this is, like...
This is Revenant.
She fucking sucks.
Uh, early game.
How are you then?
Because when you're in level one, this is your HP in level one.
In level one.
And, like...
Not...
Don't look at the feet!
I'm gonna stand on the grass so you can't look at the feet.
And...
And the reason I don't like playing...
I...
We were, like, defeated.
We should play...
What's going on over there?
You know how Revenant doesn't wear shoes?
So, like...
Instantly, when I...
When I clicked Revenant...
My entire chat was, like...
Oh my god, her feet!
It's like freaking Evanescence.
So...
Her...
Every time I try to get close to people...
To do this...
I got squished...
By the enemy.
So, like...
But...
I have summons, so I can summon people.
I didn't beat it.
They put Evanescence on the freaking trailer.
Yeah.
Do they?
Oh, they did?
That's funny.
So, yeah.
Which one?
What?
I can summon...
This guy.
I can...
I kind of want to, like, unmute it.
And just give people...
When everybody knows.
Perfect by nature!
And then...
There's Sebastian.
My little guy that can't move.
He can't move, by the way.
He just stays there.
Huh.
I think this is on my bot, Alyosha.
I'm...
I'm not really watching it.
I'll be avoiding it.
The two thousands.
Alright.
But this is Revenant.
She can heal, too.
This is her heal button.
Actually, so based for that.
I'm sorry, I was bopping.
I'm bad.
Are you bopping to the...
To the trailer?
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
I was being slightly facetious about it being Bring Me To Life.
It broke me back to old gamings.
And then I unmuted it and it was legit just Bring Me To Life.
They know their audience.
Hell yeah.
No, mana doesn't count to summons.
The summons is a skill ability.
Oh, I need to get off that table.
That gives you guys more of a POV for the feet.
Oh, and this is Lyme's favorite character, Duchess.
Should I ask what's going on over there?
She's pretty because she reminds me of like the doll.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah.
Oh, my chat really liked it when I picked Revenant.
For reasons unknown.
Is there a specific reason why?
Beep.
Yeah.
Yeah, Zen's chat.
Why do you like Revenant?
Why don't...
I'm just gonna show some of the characters as well, actually, I think.
Yeah, I'm doing that right now.
So don't ready up without me like...
Good idea.
Without giving me a warning.
No, you pick your characters during the character selection.
Oh, that's true, that's true.
Okay, okay, okay.
Also, I lowered both of them down a little bit.
Let me know if that's better, sound guy.
And if the game volume's okay still.
Oh.
I went...
Alright.
So this is Lime's favorite character.
Duchess.
She's like basically like Lady Maria.
And then she has this thing called Rewind.
So...
Every attack I do, Rewind...
Like double...
Like does it again.
But there's like a...
Cool, like...
How many seconds is it anyway, Lime?
Uh...
I don't know.
I don't think it specifies.
I was kinda just doing it based on vibes.
Yeah, just be like...
Vibe-based skillies.
Rewind time.
I like how...
I like how Revenant just brings out the claws.
Oh, you.
What is a blue attack anyway?
Which blue attack?
When you...
The character weapon skill.
You know when she does a blue attack?
Oh, it's like a magic dagger.
I think it just adds magic damage.
Oh, okay.
Here, weapon.
Rewind time.
I don't know what you're always...
You're always like invisibility, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, and...
Honestly, I feel like probably for now...
I feel like the strongest groups are gonna be just like...
The Wilder and the Iron Eyes.
Because they have the big damage ults.
Yeah, yeah.
I like this character.
She's cool.
His giant arrow isn't that...
I don't think it's like actually that much damage in general.
I think it's like...
I think the...
What...
Is the Wilder the one with the...
Where you turn to the giant dog?
No.
It's the one that Zem was playing with the hookshot.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That shit was strong.
Yeah, because he's got the big like single target or like...
I feel like the giant dog is pretty strong too.
But yeah, I think this one will be viable because like...
I can just like restage...
And do it again.
People are talking about like art...
The item...
Well, items aren't really that important, I feel like.
Well, until like end game.
I don't use my items that much.
Until like...
Uh...
Because like...
I like putting damage on my weapons.
Yeah, I usually save it for the boss fights too.
But it's like you...
But it's so easy to find items in general.
Around.
Bird guy?
No, he fucking sucks.
No, he's not a fan of bird guy, sorry.
I think maybe it's because he was...
So weird at play.
I didn't understand him.
I was so confused.
I...
He's basically the tank.
But like I was so confused.
This is a...
Like he does this.
He was more so like...
He's like more so like...
Shielding, I think, right?
It's like a shield attack.
And then...
He's like the tank of the...
Of the game.
I didn't like playing him.
I'm not a good tank.
Oh...
This one is...
This one was...
Is Zen's character.
Wilder.
I went to the wrong place.
Yeah, I'm showing chat Wilder now.
Yeah, Iron Eye is very cool.
Look at his armor.
I get the feeling...
I get the feeling that due to the range and the uptime...
Especially on some things where they were like...
Flinging themselves around the arena.
It was really hard to actually like...
Hit them with melee shit.
Guys, my game crashed.
Give me a sec.
Oh no.
That's just the first time.
Guys, I don't...
The driver update calls crashes.
Wait.
Oh no.
Really?
I don't know.
I updated my drivers yesterday.
If you're suddenly crashing and you weren't crashing before...
I never...
That's true.
I didn't crash before.
I did update my drivers last night.
Because they were like...
Hell yeah, NVIDIA.
We love you.
I did not update.
Thank God.
You're lying now.
Because I was like...
Oh, I'm stuttering.
Maybe I should update my drivers.
Maybe I...
Okay.
I need an...
I need an invite again.
Guys, the reason why I was updating drivers was because...
We were trying to figure out why I had these mini stutters.
And then like...
They're like asking me...
How long since the last time you updated drivers?
And I was like...
Oh, since like...
December 2020.
I found out it was December 2024.
So I was like...
Alright.
Maybe I should update my...
Drivers.
Alright.
Uh...
Then I need another invite.
Alright, but this is a grappling hook, guys.
I'll get you.
I like his cape.
Which one?
Uh...
Iron Eye.
Iron Eye?
Oh, yeah.
A little fab.
I don't know if it's also because like...
I'm...
I have all these stuff open now, too.
Mm-mm.
Maybe...
It could be that as well.
Because we didn't really test it out with everything open.
Oh, yeah!
Maybe!
I have 100% CPU right now.
I...
Time to turn down some settings.
Uh...
Oh, wait!
It's dropping down!
It dropped down.
I don't mind turning down the graphics a little bit, right?
Should be that bad.
Look, when we were testing this out...
Only Zen had to have stuff open, not the rest of us.
If you had like high CPU on launch, it was probably like the anti-cheat launching or something like that.
That's true.
Yeah.
I'll just turn down the graphics a little bit, just in case.
I don't feel like...
We need all...
Whoa!
Maximum!
Let's go!
Mine's not even set to maximum.
What are you doing?
Whoa!
What are you...
Is yours on maximum or high or medium?
High, I think.
Okay, okay.
My emotions are turned off.
Alright, it's on high now.
I was like, whoa!
I didn't know I was on maximum settings.
Let's fucking go!
Uh oh!
Ultimate settings.
We don't need water surface quality.
I'm not here to look at water.
Get that ray tracing.
There you go.
Yeah, I don't need to look at water as I go to look at water.
Maybe that's what I was studying.
No, no, when I...
I think the driver update put it on maximum.
Because I remember seeing it on high.
Um...
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
That's us!
We're on the stream!
We're...
We're on the stream?!
Oh my god, hello!
Just like the team info.
Oh, okay.
It was like a cool picture of Zen.
Wait, what about us?
Are we...
We're like...
We were names.
Plus ones.
We're the...
We're the lessers.
But also, thank...
Huge shout out to Zen for inviting Lime and I.
Yeah, thank you!
To this.
Yeah, it's kind of funny.
Like every time it scrolls by like the speedrunners and the pros...
Yeah!
And then the VTubers!
Let's go!
VTuber group!
Woo!
We're totally gonna win.
Yippee!
Totally!
You know what?
My goal today is that we beat the first boss.
That's all I want!
And that it won't take us six hours!
Ooh!
Alright.
V!
Zen's stream is on stream right now.
Oh, really?
Can they hear us?
Awkward.
Can they hear us, Zen?
I don't know.
Oh my god!
Hey, everybody!
Hey, YouTube!
Hey, Twitch!
I have- I have it- I have it muted right now.
Because I don't wanna like- Check me out at DokiBird at YouTube.
No!
Aw!
Can't even show my own stream.
Okay, we are about to start.
Oh shit.
Okay, hold on.
I write- oh wait, I'll write it up now.
I write it up.
Wait, where's my sound?
Sound team, is everything good?
Sorry, I keep asking my sound team.
They like, disappeared for a sec.
I'm excited.
Yippee!
We can finally start the game.
It's okay.
I'm sure I will remember everything.
Me too.
We just need to find- Do you remember where the flask places are?
Wait, who's the first one we're fighting?
The wolf.
I think it's just the guy we were doing last time.
Yeah, it's the wolf guys.
I don't know what the second or third bosses are.
Because like, it doesn't- It says like, the missions don't say who the bosses are.
Yeah, I'm assuming it's just the first three.
I don't know.
We might have to ask them like, what's the name of the mission after.
Okay.
Oh, I know we have to fight what's the name of Gladdy, whatever his name is.
And it's the first boss.
Yeah, I don't know why it's named something different there.
Oh, no, it's not randomized.
The final boss- The final boss at the end of each mission is always the same boss.
Yay.
The randomization of bosses is the- Alright, let's go.
The mini bosses we play.
God, we're going.
Okay.
Arrow guy.
Alright, we can't skip two.
Going with my favorite.
Yeah, we don't skip.
Alright guys, look at this cool intro that we saw like, 600 times.
No, we didn't die that much.
It's pretty cool though, but like, after the first two times.
Oh, I don't have my controller overlay up, but I'm not going to tab just in case something terrible happens to the capture.
Alright.
Lamu, do you remember any of the Flask are?
Yeah.
Cause I don't.
I remember the icon, yeah.
Okay.
Cause we need like, at least two.
Or one actually.
Where are we dropping?
Let's see.
Alright.
By the way, this is the map.
We might land on one.
Alright.
You see it here?
Yeah, I see it.
Let's go there then.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
Okay guys, so here's like, the map.
And you can see it's like, Battle Royale-ish.
Where there's the stone.
Do you want to run through the church really quick?
Yeah, we should get some souls really quick.
Or runes or whatever.
Look at that.
I'm helping.
Helping.
Alright, let's go.
Where's the church?
I don't know.
I'm following you guys.
I'm the follower.
I see it.
I see it too, yeah.
I wonder if we can...
Oh, I can already level up.
Nice.
Yeah.
Alright.
No, there's no friendly fire.
Thank god there isn't.
Let's clear it up.
Okay.
This one where we...
There's that boss that should be in the hole.
No, it's this guy.
Oh, it's this guy?
Oh, it's him.
Okay.
Alright.
Perfect.
I'll mark him?
Marked him?
Those who are wondering what the mark does, it basically does more damage for my team.
But we hit it.
Back, sir.
Don't worry, the archer is here.
Shooting it very slowly.
I'll mark him again.
Oh, I need my recharge, man.
Got it?
Oh my god.
It's not locking in the right...
Oh, he's almost.
He's dead.
Easy peasy.
Alright, now we run to the church.
Can we get a thing from that?
Oh, I got a bow.
Very nice.
Why is it there?
I have the great bow now.
Okay, so we want to go to the thing I first marked.
Yep.
Oh, shit.
I need the grace.
I'm going to...
I'm following Zen.
On the way.
We can kill these guys too on the way.
How much damage?
Wow!
Nice.
Oh, I missed.
Even though I'm locked in.
How?
I'm locked in!
That's it.
Mini bow time.
Locked in or locked on?
I apparently...
Apparently I was not locked on.
Because it was...
They were too fast for my great bow.
Perfect.
Yay!
Oh, you know what?
I bet you that church had a freaking key.
I remember there's usually a key in the chest behind.
But we should find...
Let me see if I can grab it before we...
I think we want to go back.
Maybe you go...
You go for the key.
And then we can go see if there's any other bosses nearby.
Sure.
Yeah, Zen!
Try and find another boss!
There's a dunk!
Let's see right down there.
Okay.
I got a talisman.
Wait, where are you Zen?
Unpin!
Oh, I see you.
I'm heading over.
That's okay.
Wait, no, that's the wrong...
Oh yeah, guys.
There's no fall damage.
It's great.
Finally a game that I relate to.
It's here.
Oh, you found the...
The key?
Uh...
There is no key.
Got unlucky.
I got a boiled prawn though.
Oh, is this like...
Is this just to defeat all the enemies?
Or...
Or is it this guy?
Yeah.
There's another...
There's another Estus there.
And another one here actually.
There's a ton of Estus chargers if you wanna go...
Make a big...
Attempt at it all.
Okay, I have like a giant bat on me.
Give me a sec.
It's fine.
Alright, nice.
Did we get...
A thing for the perfumer?
We did.
Nice.
Uh...
Ooh, a heartbow.
I got one.
Take the heartbow.
And here we gotta level up too.
We're gonna level up.
Yay!
Okay, where do we go?
Uh...
Do we wanna...
I think we wanna go to that green pin first.
Cause that's gonna be on the outside.
I think?
Question mark?
Yeah, the shot...
The ring should close soon.
I have a vault here too.
Oh, we should kill these guys for extra.
Oh, yep.
Here's the...
Take care of these guys on the way.
Yep.
We're fine.
Oh, that sucks.
This one's in the ring.
The other one's not.
Do we wanna try and divert?
Like, we could try and go for this one up here.
And then come back into the ring.
Cause this isn't...
The other one's in the next ring.
I mean, we could try.
Smart idea.
I don't know if we could make it though.
Cause the ring closes fast.
Go for it.
The first one closes less fast.
I feel like...
Yeah.
Alright.
No.
Hopper, please.
If we think we're fast...
The speedrunner knows all the routes.
No, the speedrunners are so efficient.
They were like...
They were just kinda like...
Should we go here?
Should we go there?
And they're like...
Yeah, yeah.
They were like...
We memorized all the routes already.
And I was like...
Yesterday, by the way.
Oh my fucking god.
Oh my god.
And then we were like...
What do you mean?
Here, here, here.
You jump here.
I don't know.
Can we navigate this?
Can we get back up?
Can we...
I don't know.
This can...
We're gonna die.
Oh no.
I don't want the Valiant Gargoyle.
I got this.
I'm heading up.
I changed my mind.
It sucks.
Okay.
I don't got this.
Um...
So where is the thing?
Oh, it's to my...
Here.
Yeah, go after this.
Wait, there's nothing...
Oh wait, there's one here.
There's the flask.
There's one here.
Run!
Okay, now we have five.
We don't have any more flasks.
We leave.
There's a thing at the top.
There's a thing up...
We can jump back up the cliff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Zen, do not die to the gargoyle.
Um...
That gargoyle had not lost any HP.
I'm out.
All I'm saying is that...
He does not seem to have lost any HP.
Oh shit, I went into the wall.
I'm here.
Okay.
Where do we go now?
I'm just gonna head to...
I'm gonna get straight to zone.
Oh, there's a castle.
There has to be...
Yeah, we can go into the castle.
Then there's actually...
The other...
Uh, charge thing is actually in the...
Um...
Ring.
So we can just grab that.
Yeah.
Nice and easy.
I'm gonna kill us.
Kill these.
Gas press.
That was a lot.
Oh!
The Jarman!
Jarman is here!
He's a dick.
Alright, I'm heading downstairs now.
Cause I don't wanna die to Jarman.
Okay.
I'll just drink one flash.
Just...
Yeah, this castle fucking sucks, chat.
Because there's the Jarman.
And they like...
When we first played it, we died a lot.
To the...
To the singular Jarman.
I don't know where the entrance is to this castle.
I think I went the wrong way.
Uh...
Possibly?
I reached.
I got in.
I see it.
I don't wanna do this by myself.
I'm heading...
I'm heading over.
I found the entrance.
Almost there.
Yeah.
I'm...
I'm here now.
So...
Like the first day, guys.
You have to memorize.
You actually have to know where the routes are.
I'm here.
Where is he?
Oh, it's him.
Okay, I'm all dizzy.
I'm all dizzy.
Don't let him get to me.
I got the heal.
Oh!
Oh Jesus!
I got you.
I got tapped.
Thank you.
Oh my god!
I got Zen too.
I hate him so much.
Oh shit!
I'm down!
Yeah, it's...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Careful.
Um...
I'm gonna crawl...
near...
If you can get Doki.
Yeah, I'm gonna get me too.
Oh god.
I can get you both.
I'm not moving.
Okay, I'm backing out.
I'm backing out.
That's what I was afraid of.
Do we wanna just, like, say no to this one?
I don't know.
I'm gonna try and second him.
I think he said no to that one.
Because I have a lot of souls.
I think we're under leveled for it.
Yeah.
I think we res Zen back up.
Yeah, I'm trying to...
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
He's blocking my...
Oh wait, I can maybe?
Careful.
I can.
He's blocking my shots.
He's actually blocking my shots.
Run!
I'm out.
I don't think we wanna, like, risk the loss.
Goodbye to your one level.
One fear.
We need souls.
We need to upgrade.
We need to find a grace.
Honestly.
Those guys suck.
Yeah.
We need to find, like, a level up area.
Sorry, Zen.
We love you, Zen.
We miss you, Zen.
That was such an unlucky one.
Yeah.
That's the R...
Are we good for the Estus Flask?
And then...
Yeah, guys, that's the RNG part.
We don't know exactly what boss we're gonna get.
And sometimes it could be, like, you know, the worst possible boss to encounter.
It didn't help that I was two levels down.
Is this actually one?
I'm level five now.
Oh.
Zone.
Yeah, me too.
I'm going for the Estus.
Um...
Just like the other one.
I feel like we do need...
We're so under-leveled, though.
We're only level six.
So much pain.
I feel like we're very under-leveled.
Oh, hey, Bandai!
Bandai's my chat.
And then they said...
We can try farming the runes.
They said 07 to you, Zen.
Rest in peace.
Thanks, Bandai.
I appreciate you.
Fair enough.
Let's Flask Charge here.
I bet I have so many now.
That's sick.
Yeah, I don't think we...
I've never got to six before.
There's a thing here.
We can do some more mini bosses rather than scary bosses.
Yeah, we have to.
We have to.
Oh, that is a big...
Have we even been there before?
Let's do that.
I have to.
Scary, scary.
Yeah, yeah.
Zen is one level away...
Up behind.
So...
She needs to...
Level up.
I've not been in there before.
Yeah.
Where do we go?
This weapon might be slightly slow for my character.
I wanted to try and see if we could just jump onto the chest from above.
Yeah, I saw Zen do it.
I thought she made it.
Yeah.
I was like, Zen must have made it too, right?
I tried doing style.
Yeah, it looked cool and then I saw you not make it.
It was the effort that counts.
Alright, I guess we go to the castle?
Ow.
Is there any bosses in this castle?
I don't know.
There's a chest which will have some cool stuff.
I've decided I don't like this weapon.
Yeah, but we need better weapons too.
Yeah, I don't like the moveset on this one.
Uh oh.
We're in zone.
Oh wait, we're not.
We're not.
This is the tree zone.
It's final zone.
Oh shit!
I thought that was you in there.
No.
There's a longer over here.
It's not very good.
Oh.
Oh yeah, that's not good.
Uh...
Not ideal.
That's not good.
Do you think we can quickly go grab...
There's a big chest upstairs.
I say we try and grab it before we go.
Because we are...
Yeah.
We're not...
We're not okay right now.
Oh, there's a captain here.
Up here.
We need to...
Level up.
He's here.
Okay, I'm turning around.
Oh shit!
I don't see him.
Ow.
Come here.
I'm here.
I can strike him.
Oh, nice ult!
Wait, where did he go?
Nice.
I accidentally took two.
Whatever.
Chest here.
Oh, I have a fast weapon for you.
It's a blood...
Oh please.
Blood call.
Here.
That would be great.
Um, drop it.
Level four.
Where are you?
Here?
Here.
This is a fast weapon.
Thank you.
We got a stone key, by the way.
Did you take it?
No, I...
Oh.
Take what?
Uh...
Doki dropped a weapon for me.
Yeah.
I dropped it...
I dropped it back here.
Ah.
Let's see.
I dropped it...
Is it this?
It's a blood claw.
Did those claws?
Yeah, blood claw.
We need to go, we need to go, we need to go.
It's too late.
Oh no.
Oh no, never mind.
It's on my off hand.
I see it.
Why'd it go into my off hand?
Weird.
Okay, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Run!
I'm running.
Whoa!
The storm's approaching!
Provoking?
Blood clouds in isolation?
Provoking, you could say.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, we're only level six.
Okay.
I'm not feeling too confident with those levels.
We're a little under level, but we have to...
I am only level four.
Oh!
We definitely need to level up more on the second night.
This is going to be rough.
Yeah.
Okay.
We have to coordinate this really well for this final boss.
Or not the fuck, for day one boss then.
There's heals here.
And we need it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna mark them for you.
Go back.
Go back, sir!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, I didn't see him.
Oh, I'm gonna heal.
I can see that guy behind me.
I'm just gonna ult this, fuck this.
Can't be bothered.
I can fire him at more later.
Oh, the claw's doing good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm very pleased.
Okay, boss.
Alright.
Oh, it's these guys!
I'm trying to help you.
I thank you so much, sir.
Alright, here we go.
I think we killed the little guy first, cause he's a dick.
Okay, I'm gonna go over there to mark him if I can.
Oh, I missed it!
I don't know how I missed that!
I'm helping you with it.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
I can mark him this time.
Okay.
I got him.
I marked him.
Cool.
Nice.
Oh.
Marked him in.
Nice.
Alright, help Zen.
I'm helping you.
Oh, there's mini guys now.
I have to do the mini guys.
He's on me?
I staggered him?
He's on me though.
I gotta get the little guys out.
Come on, mark him.
Staggered.
I have mark again.
Oh shit!
Goodbye.
Do you have rewind?
Cause I have ult.
Uh, one second.
Yes.
Okay, I'm ulted.
Actually, he's gonna be dead.
Dead.
Yippee!
Okay.
Alright.
Flax slowly restores HP.
Is that bad?
Is that good or bad?
Uh, it replaces the instant heal with a heal over time, I think.
Okay, we'll see how that goes.
I got it.
Cause the other two upgrades were pretty shit.
Oh, it's bad?
Too late guys!
I'm living with these decisions!
Okay, let's go over there.
Yeah.
Straight over there.
Yup.
Yeah, my other two were like, for thrust weapons.
Hopefully I get a better weapon drop this time.
Yeah.
I'll see if I...
If there's good weapons for you too.
Okay, we're good.
There's also a big enemy on the outskirts that we should grab really quick.
Yeah.
Before the thing collapses.
Oh, you have the...
Oh, hello sir!
I can...
I marked him?
I need the Bloodheld Knight.
He's on me.
Oh!
No!
I'm an archer!
Ruby's spinning!
Please!
I'm just an archer!
Yeah, boy.
Guys.
Okay, I'll mark him.
Marked.
Please, sir.
I'm just a ranged man.
We got him.
Good stuff.
Nice.
Oh, maximum HP raise.
I'll take that.
I need this.
Yeah.
Uh...
We should go here.
Alright.
Level 7.
There's also...
There's a little guy.
There's a little guy on the way.
Agreed.
I see you.
Come here, little guy.
Don't run!
Yippee!
Alright.
What is my...
Nice.
Wait.
I have improved sorceries.
Does anyone use magic here?
No.
Okay.
Well, this item's useless.
I'm allergic to magic.
I am coming over.
Yippee!
How dare you bring magic into this room?
Oh, I found it!
Like, what was I supposed to do?
Oh, hello, sir.
How are you doing today?
Oh, this guy.
The draconic tree sentinel.
Not this guy.
It's okay.
He doesn't see me here.
That's going to hurt a lot.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I marked him.
Res?
Oh, my god!
I got one shot.
I got you.
Res.
You're res.
I see.
I'm picking up what you're putting down.
And I don't like it.
Bye.
Ugh.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
What?!
He one-shot me.
Yeah.
He's on me if you can get her, Zun.
Yeah, and he's going to get me.
I'm going.
Zen, Zen, Zen!
I'm right here.
I stealthed.
Okay, nice.
Oh, my god!
Oh, my god.
Ow.
Do we abort this?
Because what the fuck?
I feel like we could come back.
Do you really want this fight?
Can we come back to him or no?
He's really tough.
He's on the outskirts, so no.
Okay, you know.
If you can res me, we leave.
Um...
He's on me.
Zen, he's on me.
You have to res her.
Yeah, if you can touch me, we go.
Yeah, he's on me right now.
We want one of the inner ones, I think.
Oh, too late.
Oh, no.
Alright, I mean...
We don't want that shit.
I left.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Yeah, um...
Okay.
That's unlucky.
I kept my levels, guys.
The archer.
Do we want to try and kill the guy in the castle this time?
Like, now that we've gotten a couple of levels?
Oh, that ring time.
Yeah, we have to get some bosses.
Let's do it.
We're so under leveled.
We have to be level 10 by the end boss.
Oh!
Oh.
What hit me?!
Zen, Zen, Zen, Zen, Zen!
I'm right beside you!
I don't know what hit me.
He can hit you from all the way over there.
I think that fireball sniped.
Why?!
I...
That's insane.
That's crazy!
I was like...
What...
What happened?
He shot me from all the way over there.
What happened to me?
I like that guy.
He goes, dude.
That's insane.
See guys, this is what we mean by RNG.
We got RNG twice with bad...
...bad bosses.
And he took that personally.
It doesn't show where the ring's going yet.
So I'm like really nervous to commit to anything.
Cause if we go down into the castle...
...and the ring is not on the castle...
...we are beansed.
I think...
I feel like it's gonna be here.
Alright, let's just...
...find a boss.
We just need to find any boss.
There's a heal here.
If we get through it really fast...
...then just we're good.
Um...
Well, then castle boss is here.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm just following.
We're in zone.
Okay, cool.
Weird grafted scion.
I've come to bargain.
Guys, the reason why my flask isn't instant...
...is because I had three shitty power-ups to choose from...
...and this was the least shitty one.
But usually the flask is instant.
We're here.
Alright.
Welcome back.
You can rewind.
I ulted too.
We're back, bitch.
And we have...
We're more leveled up now.
Oh!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I'm just an Archie.
Why me?
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
He's dead.
You're safe, Dougie.
You're safe.
I talk too much shit as the Archie.
I...
Actually, what's my...
I got a good weapon.
73?
Oh, it was a big one.
That's like five.
I don't know.
Wait.
Successive attacks plus three?
That's good.
Uh, Zen, do you want a big, bonky stuff?
Can I get this, guys, or this?
Does this work for Bo?
What's up?
Do you want this?
Uh...
Is it better than what you have?
Bo?
Okay.
Holy yes, it is.
Cool.
I'll get the Bo.
Alright.
I'm good to go.
See, guys, this is what Zen meant when all the bosses wanted to kill me.
I'm only level seven.
Oh!
I forgot to level it up!
Let's just...
I'll just find another Grace.
Oh god, no.
Um...
Uh...
Increase...
Oh!
I like that.
I have better range.
Oh, go Scarab.
Nice.
Hmm...
Okay, I have better range with my Bo.
We should kill, like, this guy.
There's a boss here.
Uh...
We're in zone, though.
Yeah, we should go kill the boss.
Hey!
I fell off.
Oh no.
That's awkward.
It's alright.
It's okay, it happens to the best of us.
Go rebound.
I know it.
You just need, like, one big YouTube video, you'll do great.
Yeah, exactly.
You can clickbait me if you want.
You can use me as clickbait.
Maybe, like, a cool collab, something like that.
Oh my god.
Okay, we killed the griffon guy that was down here?
Uh...
Vod, you skip over one hour.
No.
We haven't.
We can.
Let's go kill him.
We have to wait for his end, though.
See how much he kills us.
I'm waiting for his end.
Okay, I'll come over now.
How the heck did you guys get up there?
Um...
I landed in lava?
So freaking fast.
We should probably start because we don't have that one.
Yeah, I know.
I'm starting with you right now.
Okay.
Big damage, big damage.
Um...
He's on me, guys.
As the...
He's very slowly heading towards me and I'm scared.
This guy is very frightening.
Oh, Jesus!
That's what I meant when I said he's very slowly heading towards me.
Nope, nope, nope.
I can't...
I can't mark him for us.
Oh.
I'm...
I'm cutting in to mark him.
Are you serious?
He dodged my mark.
Oh, I have ult.
I'm gonna back up.
Oh my god, I'm like...
What the fuck?!
Shoot.
Okay.
He...
I...
He's...
Okay, guys.
Now he's up there.
He might...
He might have...
He might have cooked us.
No, no, no.
He's slowly dropping down.
And he's looking at me.
He's...
He's definitely looking at me.
Statues don't bleed!
Oh!
Yep!
There he is!
Alright.
Oh, what in the world is this guy doing?
I don't know.
He really does not like the archer.
You're being a little bit silly, buddy.
Up there.
Yeah.
Statues don't bleed!
He's looking at me again, guys!
Wait, I can mark him here.
I marked him?
Oh my...
Oh!
Wait, did we all die?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no.
Sen's still left.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Lime is one...
Lime is one hit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You need to pop me once.
Yeah.
Thank you!
Um, I think I might lose level here.
No...
I didn't even upgrade.
I didn't upgrade at all.
I have a lot of runics too.
So I have to grab my things.
Where are you guys?
Took my eyes off of it for one second.
Wait, where are you guys?
Okay, right here.
Still there.
I'm gonna try and grab my stuff back.
He's kinda low.
I'm like still under level.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Hum.
I'm gonna try...
I'm gonna try and get Lime.
Can you get me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Gotta go quick.
Okay, so let me know...
Let me know when he's coming up to me.
You look okay.
You look fine.
Okay.
Alright.
Um.
He is still looking at me.
I got her.
We need to kill him because I really...
I really need to level up.
I'm like level 6 right now.
Oh no.
Oh Jesus.
I'll get...
Can you get her?
No, I'll get her.
Oh my god.
Yeah, he's on me.
He's on me.
I got her.
I need help though.
Is he still on me?
He's really low.
He's like mad.
He has to be...
He's like mega over level for me.
Oh.
He's one hit.
Got him.
He's dead.
Yeah.
Help me with Zen.
I'm helping you.
There you go.
Can we touch this?
Wait, what?
Zen hasn't... Zen hasn't been... We didn't finish picking up Zen live!
Sorry.
I've dragged out the bird to death.
Hold on.
Me too.
Uh... We need to be careful of the ring here.
It's okay.
It happens.
Okay.
Uh, ring is up there.
We gotta go.
Hey, this is fine.
Um... Zen?
Um... Um... I'm trying to get Zen up right now.
This is fine.
The fuck is this?
Totally.
The weapon I wanted was there.
I'm trying.
My vent.
Oh, I'm not high enough level to get that.
That sucks.
I'm trying.
It's so high, but I only have arrows.
And you were three down.
There we go.
Wait.
If you rested the grease, I think that resets that for what it's worth.
Thank you.
Alright.
I totally knew that.
It sucks down here.
This map layout is ass.
I'm just gonna put that down.
Oh, I went backwards.
Whoops.
Yeah, no.
You did run towards me.
I went the wrong way.
I didn't know which way it was.
I'm trying to, like, stop him from dying.
I'm not going to fight that guy.
Nope.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
I'm trying to make sure I don't die at a zone.
My chat's like, that thing has a really good skill, unfortunately.
Unfortunately, I'm not level 10.
We'll be level 10 at soon, though.
We should be level 10 by then, right?
Hey, I took a long turn on Albuquerque.
You gotta run.
I don't know if we're gonna have levels for the boss.
I don't know for the final boss.
Yeah, I think, well, this is the final boss after this one.
No, no, no, I meant the wolf.
I'm worried about the wolf.
After this one is him, so we're gonna get maybe one level.
Whereas I think we were 12 on our winning run.
I am so scared.
Yeah, we don't have a lot of that.
Like, we were...
Oh wait, I have the semi-human queen on me here.
Yeah, I don't think we have time to kill her.
We could try.
We can kite her over here, maybe.
Yeah, I'm trying to.
I really hope there's a way out of here.
Okay, I'm ulting us.
And then you can use time.
Can you use it?
Yup, yeah, I've used it.
Look at her health.
Look at her health!
Yeah, yeah, we do have time.
She's aggroed to me, so...
She's still aggroed to me.
She's one.
We have to get it quick.
What in the world?
Um...
So, hey guys, I might be dead.
Uh, how did you get lost?
I have a really good story.
I'm gonna bring it for you.
Just letting you know.
I don't know this story.
I have a really, really good story.
I'm gonna drop this.
Zinn went the wrong way.
Oh no, Zinn.
I don't know if this is good for you.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Where?
Yeah, let's just say I'm toast.
I don't know if it is.
It looks cool though.
Oh, seven.
Oh no, Zinn is very...
I miss you, Zinn.
Zinn might be low level for the last run.
I think we're all gonna be a little bit...
Yeah.
I'm...
Whoa!
I didn't realize it started!
Yeah, the perfumes are up.
Oh my god!
Sir!
What?!
I got fire herald.
I got fire herald instantly.
Wait, Zinn isn't gonna be part of this run!
Because it started!
I just...
Oh no, she is!
She's here, she's here, she's here.
Oh, thank god.
No panic, no panic.
That scared the shit out of me.
Only bravery!
That sucks, because I'm now...
I lost my...
Should still be a good amount of level.
Did he just go mad?
I think he went mad.
Yeah.
I'm really annoyed that we got, like, screwed on the, uh...
Demi-humans...
Yeah, we got screwed over.
Because I think I would've gotten a level from that.
Yeah.
Oh god, who's it gonna be?
Oh no!
Are you serious?!
What is our idea?!
Wait, at- Okay, whoever's got the cav- The sentinel, just dodge...
And we'll kill the cavalrymen.
I'm...
I'm doing the cavalrymen right now.
With you.
Good idea.
Okay.
I'll do the one with you.
We have both of them on me.
I'm hitting him.
Uh...
Yeah, they're both on me.
They're both on me.
Arch your aggro!
Archer, aggro.
I'm just fucking chasing you around.
Stop!
I marked both of them.
What the...
I can't even use my ult.
Bro, bro, fuck you.
I have the other cavalry guy on me.
So...
Yeah.
Let me just mount him for you.
Hold on.
Yeah, that would be great.
Thank you.
I'm gonna ult then.
There you go.
You wanna rewind that?
I did.
Nice.
Good rewind.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm gonna mark him for us.
So then you can do more damage.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay, now we can help you, Zen.
Good job, Zen.
Nice aggro.
Okay.
Alright.
He's aggro to me now.
Watch the charges.
I think he's on me.
He's staggered?
Nice, nice stagger.
I'm gonna...
I say as I get hit.
Marked him?
It's incoming in from nowhere.
Oh no!
I got staggered!
I got...
He tried to pop me.
Yeah, I popped.
Thank you!
I'm gonna full heal just in case.
Cause I only have slow heals.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, Zen.
Nice.
Marked him?
He is rewound.
He's so low.
Oh.
I can mark him again soon.
Holy did not see that.
Charges coming out.
Watch it.
He's ha...
I think he might charge...
He might charge Zen?
Yeah.
Watch the AoE.
I almost have ult again.
He's buffed.
I have to regen stamina.
I have ult here?
Do you have rewind?
Yup.
Alright.
Rewind?
Rewind.
Nice.
Yeah!
Yay!
Hooray!
Oh!
Really good stuff.
Yay!
We made it to the Wolfman!
I forgot...
Oh wait, though.
We got the level up at the third boss.
Yeah, yeah.
We got the grace.
Oh, scary.
That is scary.
Alright.
Yeah.
This is where it gets a little horrifying.
Alright.
I'm level 11.
10.
Could be worse.
What was the weapon that I got?
Nebula.
Is this where I'm losing the bleed chat?
107 on that one.
Alright.
So...
This is where everything...
This is where everything sort of...
Goes crazy.
I can do the pull...
Pull blade would be fun, actually.
Yeah, this is the one I gave you, right?
Yeah.
Although, actually, it's got less damage than the claws.
So I think, actually, the claws are better.
I don't know.
I think the pull is just more range if you want to...
Do range and stuff.
Hmm...
I don't know.
I just know that...
This is where it gets crazy.
Oh, yeah.
Let's see...
Uh...
Just like last night.
Blood blade dance is good?
Okay, hold on.
Let me just get a couple of things.
I'll have some...
Oh, whoops.
I have some shitty items.
I should have picked better items.
For this.
Run.
I don't think I can afford...
This guy has prawns, if you're interested.
No, I already...
I don't have enough.
He's already upgraded.
Cool.
We'll see how it goes.
Wind blade has good and dealing bleed.
He said it's good for bleed.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm scared.
For those who are wondering...
I mean like...
This is really fun with friends, for sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is a fun...
Like...
Cause each run is different.
It's all the RNG.
So like...
For everyone who doesn't know...
The final bosses here are all the same.
In every run...
It's the same boss.
That's not RNG.
And this boss...
Is so hard.
Yeah, the pacing of it is kinda nuts.
I wish I had slightly more time to explore the map.
Like...
Sometimes I feel like we only get to see like...
A couple points of interest.
But then again, we haven't routed.
Yeah, you get to pick the final boss.
Yeah.
So like...
There's like several final bosses to do.
Um...
But like...
For those bosses, they're always...
They're the ones that are the consistent ones.
We got a little fucked by RNG with the mini bosses.
But we got a boatload of Estuses.
Yeah!
I'm gonna eat my crab.
I hate this guy cause he flies all over the frickin' place.
Jesus!
What the fuck!
Okay, I don't remember that move!
You're balls!
I don't remember that move though.
Right above.
Okay, I'm gonna say I can...
Oh my god.
I can't mark him.
He's two.
Like...
Ow.
I'm gonna try to mark him for us.
Look at him.
I marked him?
Oh, Zen.
He's on me?
He scares me.
Ah, late on that one.
He's on me still.
Coming.
I have to run across the entire ring.
Jesus!
Stop!
He's still on me!
Let me know when you're gonna ult.
I don't have ult yet.
I think you have to wait for his Zen's ult too.
Zen might have hers.
I can't mark him.
He's like...
Just about.
Oh my god.
Yeah, he's too aggressive.
Towards me.
I'm gonna try to mark him.
Oh!
I couldn't mark him there.
Jesus.
Careful, Zen.
He is poison though.
Oh.
Fire, fire.
Backing up, back it up.
Now he's three.
Whoever gets the most dogs, just dodge.
Yeah, I'll just run.
If I get the...
Oh, it's Zen.
Zen's away!
We're slowly coming over!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I got another dog on me!
I got a dog in me!
I have four dogs on me!
I'm gonna try to concentrate on murdering this one.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, they're all gone.
Okay, if you...
Get rewind!
Uh, nope.
I got one shot.
Holy shit.
Couldn't see because the other dog was in the way.
Um, if you could get...
Lime.
I have two of them.
I have two of them on me.
Wood!
Okay.
It sucks because, like, sometimes they just come out of nowhere.
Like, the dogs...
The fireball's annoying because if there's a dog in the way, it's like, good luck seeing it.
I have my ultimate.
Okay.
Give me a countdown.
Zombie?
I can never get to it.
Use your ultimate if you have to.
Like, it is what it is.
Because I'm having trouble.
Okay, I'm on him.
Okay.
Can I mark him?
No, I couldn't mark him!
Fuck!
He went for me before I could mark him.
Are you serious?
I couldn't even get up!
Just heal, just heal.
You guys can.
I'm only one hit.
So I should be fine.
Okay, you're good?
Yeah, I'm good.
Oh, stun.
Nice stun.
Nice.
I'm marking him.
I got the mark.
That's good, that's good.
Fireball, fireball!
Alright, who's gonna be with the most?
Oh, they're on Zen.
Oh, it's all on you!
All on you live!
All on you!
I have one of them on me.
I'm okay.
I just have one.
I still have one, so it's five.
They're all on Zen now.
They're all on Zen.
Oh, careful Zen.
Do you have enough flasks?
How many flasks do you have left?
Yes, bitch!
Oh, no.
Zen is only one.
I have two on me.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, where's Zen?
I see her.
I got her, I got her.
Yeah, yeah.
I have two of them on me.
Trying to heal.
Fuck, okay.
I'm backing out.
I'm trying to back out.
You can aggro them so I can heal.
Oh, they pull me back.
He's on me.
Because I have slow heal.
I have ult.
I'm ulting.
I don't know if you have rewind, but...
No, come on.
No, I got my ult.
My ult hit you.
That was so good.
Nice.
Thank God.
You stood just there with him.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
He's on me.
Do not panic.
He's poison too.
Zen doesn't have flask anymore.
I have two though.
I have two.
Oh, I have one.
Use your items if you got them.
Don't forget.
I'm gonna have one now.
Fireballs, back up.
He's on you.
Oh.
Okay, I got one on me.
Oh, no.
They're all three on you.
Three on you.
One on me.
Dodging, dodging, dodging.
Two on me.
Three on me.
I'm just running.
Just stay alive.
Staying alive.
I have to recharge stamina.
I always have my ult.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna try and get Zen if I can.
Okay.
I'm trying my best.
So, keep going.
Yeah.
He's one.
I got you, Zen.
Marking.
I'm gonna try and market this.
I marked him.
He's so low.
If you killed this guy, he wins.
Yes.
Oh.
We did it again.
Oh, we did it.
I'm on stream.
What if you're finished here?
Oh!
Holy fuck.
What if you finished?
Oh my God.
I don't know how I had the most levels.
I don't...
Don't worry if that's fine.
Oh my God.
My dog's cheering on me.
He's so proud of me.
Yay!
Yay, Izzy should be.
Oh my god.
Guys, we have two other bosses.
No, honestly, it's fine.
Because, like, you know, if we lose the other bosses, we've never seen them before.
Yeah, yeah, guys, we've never seen those two bosses before.
The others have.
We don't know what they look like.
Oh, that was intense.
That poison was so good.
I'm so glad I had poison arrow in the end.
I know, that was really sexy.
And then at one point, I used my ult and got, like, a massive amount of bleed and they were completely ignoring me.
I got, like, the double trigger.
It was so hot.
Oh my god.
Was the dual blades really good for you?
Yeah, honestly, I think fast attacking with bleed was amazing.
Because I can, like, immediately proc my ability after the bleed and get, like, a lot of self damage.
That's good, that's good.
Oh my god.
That was intense.
We don't know what goes on in the second or third boss now.
We...
Oh my god.
When, like, when Nightline...
When you got knocked down, you were, like, right there in the vicinity of the boss from my ult.
So that's why it hit you.
It insta-rised you.
Yeah, I just instantly got back up.
Yeah, yeah.
You were literally perfectly aligned to my ult.
That was fucking great.
Because I was like, I don't know how we're gonna get you.
Are you mad?
Why are you mad?
My dog's mad.
All the shouting.
Oh, I'm just glad we didn't die in that run, honestly.
I'm so...
From the practice that we've done.
We didn't go out like bozos in round one.
That means we are so locked in then.
Alright, I think he wants to eat.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm gonna feed my dog.
Oh, apparently they're showing highlights and stuff on the stream, so we should go check that out.
Did anybody wipe or everybody passed?
I don't know.
I'm back.
I'm glad.
I'm glad we two teams wiped apparently.
Oh!
Not us!
As long as it's not...
Nah, don't worry.
Next run, it might be us.
I'm watching...
Ooh, these guys went into...
Is that the mausoleum or is it underneath the castle?
I'm not sure.
I think after that rough round.
To be fair, I'm...
I'm glad...
I'm surprised we managed to...
This is good luck next.
I'm surprised we managed to make it to the...
To the...
Like, we managed to win that one.
Because our RNG was so fucking bad for that run.
Cause like...
We nailed it.
We were great.
Yeah, cause this is the...
Cause like...
The fact that we couldn't defeat two bosses for levels.
And we...
All of us lost levels too.
Yeah.
We still managed to defeat them.
I'm very proud of us.
Me too.
Oh.
Thank God.
I didn't know you could climb up there and do that.
You guys are so wicked.
They're showing highlights from like the speed running teams.
And it's like, wait, you can do that?
Where's the...
Where the...
Where the frick is the magma worm?
I have no idea what any of these things are.
They're showing that like...
Yeah.
I...
Did you see the prizes?
They're like, here are the prizes for the first team.
Actually.
I'm like, yeah, the speed...
Oh, okay.
Speed runners are getting...
That's so cool.
I can't wait to see those at the speed runners place.
Oh man.
I'm proud of us though.
I'm proud that we...
Yeah.
That we got that.
We...
We got...
We got the one thing.
We did what we set out to do.
And then we're gonna kill everything else, of course.
But...
Yeah.
The fact that we did it all on stream.
The first boss.
Live on stream.
Not off stream.
Apparently, my chalicean, the twin blaze, was actually a really good weapon I pulled for you.
Yeah, no.
It was so good.
Uh, the art that I used.
I just started like...
When I was invisible, I just started flailing on one of the wolves' ass.
And it did so much damage.
Yeah, yeah.
Cause of the bleed.
Cause it was a bleed and poison too.
Yeah.
Cause I'm pretty sure we were under leveled for that boss.
I'm fucking sure we were.
Oh.
Yippee!
We did it!
Woo!
Pressure mildly reduced.
I...
Yeah.
We don't know what's going to happen in the next two missions.
So like, if we die, like, it was expected.
Cause we don't know what we're...
What the plan is.
Yeah, people were saying recommended level for the final boss is level 12.
And I was the highest level at level 11.
Only.
I was 10.
Yeah.
And Zen was nine.
We have trouble finding enough levels.
I need to level...
We obviously need to like...
I don't know, then max it somehow.
Well...
It was just like...
We missed two bosses, remember?
And we also lost...
Like...
Zen lost two levels.
I lost one level.
So like...
Um...
I should've been level 12.
Right, right.
Yeah.
Oh man, wait, they're showing highlights.
They're gonna show us fighting like...
And we still locked in.
The...
The first guy underneath the castle and then being like, Nope.
Nope.
Alright, they're showing highlights.
They better show my all rest.
That shit was cool.
Yeah.
They're...
They're showing highlights right now if you go onto the stream.
That shit was cool.
That was my highlight of the day.
Or like, they could show highlights of all the bosses chasing me.
Oh...
I see.
Yeah.
That would be fun.
I liked it when we were trying to leave and that guy was...
Or no...
He was just jumping on you in the exit.
It was like, Please no.
Yeah.
I was like, Hey!
I was like, fuck you!
And then he took it personally.
I don't know which team they were.
It was Saikuno's team.
And like, they had like, I don't know.
A thumbnail left of health on the final boss.
And wiped.
No!
Yeah.
All three of them were dead or...
That's freaking rough.
Who was the last person?
I don't know.
That lived on their team.
Aw, that sucks.
You should fill your...
Oh!
Apparently...
Apparently if we fill up our weapon slots, the passives for the weapons also stack up.
Oh!
So we should just...
So we want to be getting as many weapons as possible.
Yeah.
So we can collect them for their...
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
See, I was...
I remember like...
Both hands?
Yeah, both hands.
Okay.
I remember off stream chat, I was like, I wish I was streaming this so my chat can backseat me right now.
Yeah.
There's so many games like that where I'm like, I don't know what I'm doing, dude.
I was like, man, if this wasn't early access, my chat could tell me all the...
what to do.
Yeah.
So we could...
So look, guys, we were so nerfed, guys, but we...
So grab six weapons then for all the benefits.
Yeah.
Yeah, basically.
That's what they say.
I didn't know that.
It's good to know these things because it like people...
People will go onto the speedrunner stream and...
Yeah.
People who like know the games and then they'll come back and be like, Hey team, secret info on how to actually play.
They said if the...
If the ability shows...
I want you guys to know that we did that without...
We would beat this boss without even knowing that.
Exactly, guys.
It makes it even more impressive.
We...
We totally nerfed ourselves.
It makes it more impressive and we have no clue what we're doing.
We totally nerfed ourselves on purpose, guys, to show you that anyone can defeat the boss.
Oh, they say if the icon has a hand icon, then you have to wield the weapon for the passive.
But if it doesn't, then the...
It's a...
Then it will like...
It can stack up.
Okay.
Yeah, it was a flex.
We just love the challenge.
Should we ready for the next one?
Just so when they're ready.
Oh, I already read it up.
So it's just Zen.
Do you know which one it's supposed to be?
No.
Okay.
Zen, do you know what?
Zen's the only one that needs to know which one it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, Zen, you played a beta.
You didn't know that?
You didn't know about the passive stacks?
The weapon stacks?
Apparently it was in beta.
Oops.
Wait, no, Lime, you played a beta too!
No, I didn't.
Oh, you didn't?
I never played.
Oh, wait, I thought you said you liked...
I remember you said you liked the Duchess.
Or something before.
No, I said she looked cool.
Oh!
She totally played.
Wait, Bandai is in my chat to give me tips!
I remember, she totally played.
Whoa, Bandai!
Yeah, you know what?
I love tips!
I'm gaslighting us!
No!
I've never played...
I've played all the same games, but I haven't played this.
Wait, how come you're giving her tips, but not me?
You don't need tips, Zen.
You're too good.
That messed up.
Hot tip, hot tip, don't die.
Okay, well, I'm banning Bandai Namco US.
Sorry.
Bandai, I'll never ban you.
I'll always support you.
And I'm always free to do any sponsor you want me to do.
Hit me up.
I'll even mod you.
Wait, wait, wait.
Mod for sponsor.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, man.
You typed really fast.
I wonder if...
Is there any other teams that are still going?
No, we were the last ones.
Were we the last ones?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we were the last ones to finish.
That's right.
Wait, that means everybody watched us.
Apparently, we were on the stream at the very end.
There it is.
Yeah!
Everyone watched us.
Let's go.
Which is Libra?
Good question.
I feel like the names you were given, I don't know which ones they are for the missions.
Um, I think you might have to ask them then.
Maybe Chad knows.
Guys, do you guys know which mission is the Libra one?
I don't want you to do it.
Chad hasn't seen it.
No, I'm showing them the...
I'm showing them all the names of the missions.
That one.
It says something related to a goat.
Oh, yeah, because it's a Libra.
The goat man with the eyes.
Yeah.
Pointing.
Yeah, that one.
Equilibrious beast says Bandai Namco.
A little bit of a late start, but it's fine.
Thank you Bandai Namco!
Yay!
Yeah, Libra is goat.
Oh wait, are we going?
Oh shit.
Um, so this is our first time in this mission.
So good luck to us.
I believe in us.
Yeah.
I have complete and utter faith.
How long is the average run?
An hour.
And then the next one will be that one.
Okay.
Is it a different map?
I don't know.
We've never tried the other missions before.
Yeah, this is the first time we've seen any of this.
Yeah.
If we can beat the first one, we can do the second one.
We're just going to first try the boss.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, we got this.
No, I think...
Is this the same map?
I think so, right?
Guys, I have bad news.
Yeah.
What?
What's that?
What is it?
I have to go pee.
Oh.
No.
Wait.
I'm sorry, you don't get to go pee.
They say that, like, if you hold your pee, you play better.
That's true.
No, it's actually true.
The tension and anxiety of it.
Yeah.
You're not like this?
It'll be good for you.
Everybody?
I'm doing my little pee dance.
Don't mind me just picking up tons of weapons now.
Okay, we gotta find...
Find...
Find some bosses.
My game crashed!
Oh, shoot.
That's nice.
Can I get back in?
I don't know, can you?
I don't know.
I...
Yeah, no, it tries to restore session.
Come back in.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We need to get in here.
Yeah.
Uh, then we should just keep running.
Yeah, just keep running.
Just keep running.
And then we'll see how it goes.
No!
There's gonna be a boss here, right?
I need to absent my Travis!
You literally just flew across the screen.
No!
It's cause I told her to hold in her pee!
She said adios.
Guys, don't update your drivers.
Giant Red!
I got guilt-tripped into updating my drivers, guys.
I will say, I got guilt-tripped into updating my drivers.
Uh, I think the Guardian Golem might be above us.
Then we should run off.
Not like this.
I'm trying to...
Uh, please use when you wish value.
Yeah, I'll be right up there.
Can I reconnect?
Oh!
Okay.
If I'm beating your driver doesn't work, clearly what you have to do is upgrade to Windows 11.
Wait, I think I'm coming back in.
Okay!
I think I am.
Where the frick is this Golem?
Don't worry!
Free souls!
Oh my god, I hope it like gives me the souls you guys were farming.
Oh yes!
I'm at 480!
Did you got... did I...
Oh my god, where am I?
I...
I'm coming over.
I still can't find the Golem.
We have found no boss.
I don't know where he is.
Hold on.
Is he like up the stairs?
I'm gonna go looking for him.
We'll farm...
We'll farm some mini stuff because I don't think I got the souls when I disconnected.
I think he's in there.
I think he's at the top.
I don't know how to get there.
Okay, I'm gonna level up right now.
Oh, you...
You found him?
I didn't find him.
Okay, I'm level 2 now.
How do you get to him?
Wait, where are you guys?
In a castle.
I am...
Wait, up top?
Yeah, there's like a Golem up top.
Don't know how to get to it.
Hope this helps.
Okay, I'm figuring how to get inside.
I'm like...
I can hear it.
Okay.
Oh, I see Zen beating him up.
It's okay, we can get...
I see him!
Coming!
Um...
I'm not there.
I'm trying to figure out how to get inside.
Oh no, I might not get that level up.
I think you get the level.
No, but I don't get the level up though.
Wait, I'm lost.
I don't know how you guys got there.
I went around the castle.
How do you get in?
Awkward.
Uh...
Through the sewers.
Sewers?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
To the window.
I'm going through the sewers right now.
To the walls.
Fuck it, I'm not going to take the...
And then you go up and up the intersection.
No, let's just move on.
Because I don't want to waste time.
Okay, let's do this camp then.
I'm here.
It's fine.
I think it's just an...
Um...
I think it's just like...
Uh...
Just an item, right?
Mostly.
Because usually the first boss is just an item.
Yeah.
It was a...
So it's alright.
Alright.
Where's the next boss?
Because we have to...
We have to grab...
The night tie is growing stronger.
We only killed one boss.
And we need to...
This is going to be another rough round.
We need to get a flask too.
Oh god.
Are we in the ring?
We're not in the ring for this.
So we have to kill it fast with Zen.
Yep.
I'm stuck on fucking rock.
Where's the...
Where's the boss for this?
It's a group.
It's the red main knight.
So we just gotta kill everything.
Nothing...
Oh wait, here?
I think we can do it.
Yep.
Wait, nothing is lowering HP though for me.
It's full HP for me.
Unless it's these guys.
Oh, it's these guys.
It's a big guy.
Okay.
What the fuck?
I need him.
I see him.
I'm gonna...
Nice.
We're gonna find one more.
Good stuff.
Oh, he got fiended.
Is this one?
No.
I hope that guy's not all the way up there.
Yeah.
Where is the last one?
I don't see him.
Oh my god!
Who is...
He's way up here.
I think.
Who is throwing the purple?
Oh, there's a guy with a bow and arrow up there.
Jesus!
Bro, fuck that guy.
Like, it's hitting me.
I don't know how to get up there.
How did you get up there, Zen?
Oh, it's from here.
Oh no!
Alright.
Good luck, guys.
Kill him!
Nice.
We did it!
Yay!
We did it.
Oh, there's a...
Oh...
There's the number of runes obtained.
Oh, I got, uh, fire claw for you.
I can hear...
I can hear the...
Thank you.
I can hear the thing coming and we should do it over there though.
Okay.
Running, running, running, running, running, running...
Uh, there is an Estus here, where I pinned.
There's actually one here as well.
Oh, there's three.
I didn't see them, but we can still get to two.
Yeah, yeah.
We need at least two.
Oh god, I don't see a way.
I'm following Zen.
Oh no.
Zen and I might die.
Yeah, I know that feel.
Oh no.
Dude, there's no way to get up.
Oh, I might die to Zen.
I found my way.
Oh, why did I follow Zen?
Oh, why did I follow you, Zen?
Oh, and I'm gonna lose my runes!
I knew it.
Follow a lamb.
Oh...
I lose my runes too, because I couldn't level up.
I'm so sad.
I was led astray.
I was led astray by the false prophet.
I thought he was... I thought Zen was captain.
So she knows where to go.
The false prophet.
Of course I die.
The captain survives.
Let's go.
I lost 28k runes and I'm level one.
Uh, if you get to where I am...
I'm not going down with the ship.
There is a... an altar.
Oh, and a big dragon.
Um, I can't help much because I'm level one.
Oh dear.
Where is the... where is it, Lyme?
Uh, my mark.
I don't see the mark.
I'm level one!
I didn't get to...
Yeah, Kazuki got disconnected, do you remember?
Yeah.
Wait, where is it?
Mine?
The flats?
Yeah, that's why.
There.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah, and there was no grace.
It's always the same building if you can get to it.
There was no grace with... next to that first boss we killed.
Don't worry.
We will protect you.
I'm so sad.
Yay.
We could try and kill the dragon, but I vote we go and fight somewhere to spend our souls.
Um, I have nothing... I can't spend... I need 3,000 souls to be level two.
Yeah, me as well.
Because I only have 400.
Let's hurry up and get up there.
You know what?
I will always fall alive.
Never follow Zen again.
Zen is famous for her sense of direction.
Actually, my sense of direction is usually terrible.
Yeah, but you live.
I got lucky.
Yeah.
I need, like, more runes because I'm, like, only at 400.
Uh, there might be someone in here.
What the fuck?
But I'm gonna go get this thing.
I actually need... I need, like, um...
That should count towards something.
I can't level up, though.
We need to fight a boss, because I...
Uh, this thing probably has something.
We're very under...
Like, I think overall we're very under leveled.
Oh, it's these...
Where's the boxes?
I don't know.
We're looking.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm trying to find if there's anything here.
Isn't I just saw a tunnel?
Yeah, but the...
Oh, wait, there is a tunnel.
Yeah.
Uh, I found a thing, but I don't think it's a boss.
No, it's just...
Oh my god, I'm so under leveled!
Ugh.
Oh, what the fuck?
I'm still looking for stuff.
I just want...
Okay, I can level up.
Oh, castle's here.
Do you wanna go to the castle?
Alright.
Where are you?
We can do that.
Yeah.
Oh, there's also this thing here.
But, did we go here?
Oh my god!
I don't know if we went here.
I'm a giant here.
I'm a little lost.
I don't know where you guys are.
Uh, look at the map.
I have an icon.
Wait, are you green or blue?
Uh, I'm not sure.
I'm green.
Okay, I'm gonna go to Lime.
Wait, Lime, are you the one fighting...
boss right now?
Yes!
Okay, I'm heading over.
Nice!
I was there.
Good stuff.
I got one of the bosses.
I'm helping Lime with the other one.
Wait, does it...
Do you have level ups with that boss?
Zen?
Is there like a level up item there?
Yeah, I loved up.
I'm going over to Zen.
I need to level up.
Sorry, Lime!
Okay.
I need this more.
Yippee!
Where's that level up item?
Zen, you false prophet!
You false prophet!
So, oops!
I almost died to the ring again without lifting up!
About to do this fast as the ring is closing.
Okay, I'm level three.
I'm very...
Good job!
Very under level.
She's doing it.
Uh, there's one more Estus here.
She's beginning to believe.
I'm not.
I'm not believing anymore.
We should grab that before we go.
I feel like such a baby.
No, we're not gonna get there in time.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm feeling pretty confident about this run now.
Wait, I still have...
Do you still want the claws I got for you?
I don't know if you have a better weapon though.
Uh, I have no idea if I have a better weapon.
What level of the claws?
Wait, can we...
Oh, can we even kill this boss in time or no?
Uh, no, I'm running fast.
Okay.
Personally, I don't know.
No, I believe you.
You got to go.
Yeah.
No, I believe you.
Oh my God.
I've never been level three for the first run.
Bastards.
No.
We can get it for it.
We can get it on day two.
Oh, icky hand, icky hand, icky hand, icky hand.
I hate that.
These are my least favorite things in the entire world.
Oh, yeah.
I'm very weak, by the way.
So, like...
Wait, what the fuck is this?
Oh, big hand!
I have to help this.
I got the extra flask.
What the fuck is going on with my weapons?
Wait, how did you get the extra flask?
I fucked up.
Did you go inside the...
Oh no, I know what I did.
That sucks.
What?
I fucked up.
Yeah, I went to go get it.
I mean, the flask will still be there, so...
We can grab it on day two.
I accidentally used magic.
I feel dirty.
Alright.
No!
You get it.
It can heal you.
Send a beat demon!
Oh god!
I've never seen him before!
I marked one of the heads.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
I don't know how much damage I am contributing.
But like...
I am trying.
You're doing great, sweetie.
As a level three.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I marked him first.
Oh, ew.
What is this?
I marked him?
Oh!
Dead.
Okay.
Who's...
Is it me with the poison?
I don't know.
I didn't check my stuff.
Uh...
I don't know if it's me.
I'm sorry.
Hold on.
Oh, it...
It's me.
Oh, it's you?
Okay.
Nice.
I'm gonna mark him for us.
He's marked?
It's the center head.
Oh, now it's a body.
It's a body.
When you hit that body, you get more damage in.
I have ult.
Do you have to rewind?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm ulting this?
Big damage.
Ult it?
I staggered him with it.
He went down.
And I...
And I marked him too.
Ow.
He's...
I got real scared about how far that was going.
Yeah, me too.
I don't remember this guy at all.
I just have instant hit, I feel like.
Whoa!
Nice, we did it.
Someone's like, cut off his tail!
It's just that easy.
I remember this inflict bloodloss when HP is successive attacks.
Do I do a successive attacks, chat?
Does the bow do that?
Or no?
Quick, carve the tail!
Wrong game, guys.
Wrong game.
Yes?
Okay.
Try that.
Thanks, chat.
I love having chat to backseat me and pick my stuff.
Uh, so there's Estus here.
Actually, there's Estus here, which is further out, so we should go there first.
I'm gonna get to the one in front of me first.
The one in front of you?
Yeah.
The one where Zen and I are at.
The one, the one I trust.
Oh wait, we spawned on one, okay.
Oh yeah, because I was there last time.
Okay, we grab that, then we go to the marker.
Uh, on the...
Actually, uh...
There's a jail cell.
We should do, we should do jail after the Estus.
We have five Estus.
I think six is, like, the optimal.
Yeah, so we go to the other Estus, and then we collapse in and get the jail.
What were the...
Oh god.
All the enemies are in the center, dude.
What were the black marking ones again?
I don't remember.
Hm?
You see the map?
There's, like, it's, like, black.
The shining ones.
Black circles?
The black shining things on our map.
Uh, I don't know which one you mean.
Like, the black one with the red outline?
What are those?
Oh, those are, those are the big bosses.
Oh, okay.
So we can do those, but...
They're the harder ones, so if we're behind, it might, like, you know, death spiral.
Oh, oh, like...
We might not, like, have enough levels for it.
Yeah, we might not be strong enough, and it might be a waste.
I get it.
You guys say it's three realms?
It's three bosses, right?
Huh?
It's, uh, three different, uh...
Yes.
Expeditions, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So this one is the second one, and then we have one more after that.
Okay.
Yippee!
I keep trying to keep an eye out for little glowing buffs, because those have things like, you know, increased runes.
Yeah.
Uh, got me, which is nice.
All right, last, last.
Yeah.
And then there's that here.
I think we get that, and then we go into the jail.
Because I have...
Mm-hmm.
Whoa!
Whoa, I did not...
I thought that was said for some reason.
One of my chat members says, this reminds me of Elden Ring.
Yeah!
Just a little bit of tomfoolery.
Oh my god, you're so ahead of us.
I'm trying to...
Yeah, I don't know...
I don't understand this ruin, if there's something here.
Oh, this is the place where I couldn't find anything.
Fuck this place, I'm going to the jail.
All right.
I'm just following that.
Oh, I thought I fucked up.
Getting from some vibes, hell yeah.
What?
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Guys, I might be behind.
Uh, I'm going to wait for you guys to pop this jail.
All right, you guys are going to fight that jail cell.
I'm sure she's going to be all right.
You're going to fight that jail cell without me.
You can get here in time, I believe in you.
Hit it.
Don't worry, I'm all...
Yeah, just hit it.
Hit the jail cell.
I'm heading over.
I fucked up.
I fell down a hole.
I don't know how I got there.
I'm here!
Ow.
Hello, guys.
Hey.
Did y'all miss me?
Yes.
There you go, I marked him.
You should be able to do more damage than I got.
Nice.
They're nice too, on her.
Hey, Zen, you having fun?
I'm gonna ult this.
They are slowly poisoning to death, which is crazy.
There you go.
If you have rewind.
I don't think I was close enough for rewind to work.
I don't know.
Oh, crap.
Marked?
He should be able to close.
Oh, shit!
I got him, I got him.
Nice.
There's one more on Zen.
Coming for Zen.
Got you.
I used to dead.
Oh my god, Zen, you were one HP.
Did you hookshot to him and then he fucking just exploded you?
Raises potency of sorcery?
No, I need 10,000.
I'm so behind.
I need these runes.
Fuck you.
We could try this guy, but I think the ring's gonna come in.
So, I don't know.
Alright.
Oh, he's a little lizard.
Kill the lizard.
We can give it a try at least.
I think we've got just enough time.
Yeah, yeah.
I already used my ult, so I just don't have my ult.
Oh, there it goes.
Yeah, we gotta get this bad in.
Just stay behind him, because he likes doing a lot of things behind in front of him.
Mike McGaWyrm!
I can go closer and mark it for us.
Oh, fuck!
Nevermind!
Guys!
I think we go because we're not doing any damage.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys!
Don't let me don't know!
Guys, I'm coming for you!
I'm coming for you!
Guys, please!
Don't make me lose another level!
Run!
I'm running!
Don't say goodbye, Doki!
Zen, I'm gonna remember that when you...
When you get down!
I am not shooting my arrow!
I am not shooting my arrow to res you, Zen!
Just remember that first run!
Ah,
I'm heading to the castle if you wanna get the guy underneath.
Doki will remember that.
I will absolutely remember that.
There's another Estus on the inside.
Me, when I make all the wrong decisions.
Uh, I think we can get over here.
Yay.
Hey, buddy.
These guys are always in the same place too, which is cool.
Yeah.
Oh, you want to go into the castle, all right.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going down underneath the castle.
We can get that boss there.
Because there's also, there's always that chest as well afterwards.
Yeah, that's true.
Items and stuff.
Yeah.
Good idea.
Oh, hey, buddy.
Are you serious?
I'm not having a very... Dogeberry is having a terrible, a terrible no good day.
Then he farted all over him and now I can't see him.
There he is.
Oh my god.
I didn't lock him for that.
Nice.
I'll mark him too.
Oh, that was a lot of damage.
I can ult this too.
That was a rewind.
That was pretty hot.
I can ult this too.
Got the ult.
Nice.
Yeah!
Fudging beautiful.
Do I do crit... I do do critical hits, right?
Oh, I have a good weapon for Zen, but I'm not going to get it.
Zen, do you want this really good weapon that I have that's purple?
Say you're sorry.
I can rise from being defeated once.
Say you're sorry right now, Zen, and I'll get this weapon.
I'm so sorry.
Why is the... why is the screen shaking?
Yeah.
I dropped it.
Don't want it.
Oh, shit!
I'm out.
At peace.
If he follows me up here, I'll fight him, but I'm not fighting him down there.
Yeah, I'd love to.
Oh my god, oh, he's here!
Run!
Why me?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm faking my...
Please, please get me out of here.
Why me?
Please, let me grab my weapon!
Okay, I got my thing.
I got my thing.
God, I'm so sick with it.
Oh my god, there's another one!
There's another one coming!
Okay.
Oh!
Get him.
Goodbye!
Thank you, Bandai.
I really...
We did back...
We did not say thank you.
Did I just say goodbye?
No, Bandai was like behind you, Doki, after I got slapped.
Thank you, Bandai.
I really...
I really appreciate it.
We appreciate it.
Yeah.
Get more devs like Bandai.
Guys!
Oh, what in the world?
There's another one.
There's so many.
What the?
Creasible Knight's here to make sure nobody has a good day.
Yeah.
I marked him.
Got it.
We...
I need a grace.
We need to find one before we get to the boss.
Because I...
I really need to level up.
Nice.
There we go, we got it.
Improve incantation.
What in the world just happened?
All right.
Can you guys take me to a grace?
I really need to level up.
I'm sorry.
I just realized you...
Can you take me to a grace?
Like, mom and dad, please, please, please take me there.
I...
I need to level up, please, mom and dad.
I fell down the fucking hole.
How do I get out of the hole?
Hey, guys.
What the hell it is?
Give me a sec.
Dookie has lied all the way into the stream.
I got it.
I'm okay.
I'm going to the...
Mom, Dad, I'm leaving.
Okay.
We need a grace.
There's one.
Oh, there's a big...
There's a big enemy and also there's one more Estes.
Do you want more Estes?
Oh my god, I'm level nine.
Thank god.
Okay, we gotta see if we can get one more fight, boss fight in before we go.
I just went up three levels because of this.
We want to go to the Estes.
We could try and deliver the big guy on the way.
Yeah.
Here we go.
I think it's your rewind.
The rewind gives me a stutter.
The rewind stutters, yeah.
No, it's always me too.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
But the ones you were getting at the very start was not the photo of the rewind because I didn't have it.
Yeah.
Yeah, but the mini-studies was...
I think it's like the crack...
I don't know.
Okay, we do not have time to fight the dudes.
Yeah.
My personal suggestion is we run...
Oh god.
We're gonna get fucked by this lava again.
I feel it.
No.
I hope we can get like at least one boss in.
Worse.
Okay, we got to go around.
We don't have time to go around.
I don't think.
The tree is so far.
How do we get to the tree?
Yeah, I think the thing is gonna collapse in on us.
How do we get there?
I'm gonna go with Lime.
Lime, where are you going for it?
A mistake has been made.
Hey, Lime, how did you get there?
Uh, I jumped down and then I used the...
A little bit of a silly.
...thing to go up.
Okay.
I'm scared now.
I'm very scared.
Oh, did you have to run past the boss for it?
I see something I can use.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, please.
Please don't.
I have decided that this map modifier is very mean.
That is the worst thing you could possibly use right now.
Please.
What in there?
I'm struggling.
This is the worst run I've ever had.
I'm so scared.
Me too.
Oh, shoot.
Is it closing?
Is it right behind me?
It's right behind me, isn't it?
I hit a wall!
Are you fucking kidding me?
All right, well, team, I made it.
So we're good.
Oh my god.
Goodbye to your level.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I hit a wall.
Oh my god.
Hey, then.
You made it.
Oh my god.
It's almost like I can still hear her.
Don't worry, I'm heading over.
She's almost here.
I think she made it.
Just don't fall down the little lip there.
I'm almost there.
This is my worst threat.
Look at Zach.
They're running along.
Look at her go.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Ah, don't worry.
Help me here.
There goes my hero.
I'm so proud of you.
I'm here.
I did it.
I lost two flasks for this, but I'm here.
I'm not here.
I'm alive.
It's go time.
That's all that matters.
Okay.
Things are okay for Doki.
I didn't manage to get some good weapons, by the way.
My weapons were honestly pretty ass.
Well, it's actually weird.
When you have multiple weapon passes, like you're supposed to have, things actually like die.
Uh, there's something being rezzed.
Who's doing the rezzing?
I don't know.
I'm just shooting.
Yeah, because I got rezzed.
What a dick.
I just shoot.
And that's all...
Oh wait, what?
Do we have to kill all of them at once?
I don't know.
Or if it's just that there's a mob rezzing things.
I haven't worked that out.
I don't know either.
I'm just...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Are they like skeletons where you have to hit them on the floor?
Hold on.
I don't know.
Yeah, okay.
Just hit them.
Just hit them again once they're down.
Hit them again once they're down.
You gotta double tap.
All right.
What the fuck?
You pushed me off!
As an archer, I should not front that.
No, I'm not okay.
I'm not frontlining again.
Oh, is this fucker?
Okay, I...
Yeah, rewind.
Do you have rewind?
Yup.
Okay.
No, I don't like this guy.
Rewind.
Okay.
Wait, he's easy.
We got this.
Why would you talk shit?
He's easy, guys.
He's so easy.
Okay.
Because I am the one.
I need to recharge my stamina.
Recharging stamina?
This is the guy that picked me up.
I remember him.
Yeah.
Oh, right.
Whoa.
Don't want that.
Yeah, I can't mark him because he's like...
I'm in the shit.
I can't get close to him for...
For marking.
Okay, never mind.
He doesn't care.
He wants me to be closer to him.
Okay, that's cool.
Oh, that's sorry.
I didn't mean that.
You do not have to get closer to me.
I...
No!
Oh, you're welcome.
Hey, Doki.
Thanks for being our tank, Doki.
No, please.
No, I'm sorry.
I don't want to be close.
I'm not playing.
You're using our natural taunt passive.
Thank you for the help.
I'm just...
I'm just the archer!
Please!
Guys!
I didn't know you could.
Archer can be the tank.
Jesus.
All right.
You're welcome, guys.
You're welcome.
It's really impressive if you think about it.
I'm here for you guys.
He's looking at me.
Guys, can you poke Zen?
Where is she?
Oh, there she is.
Well, I hope he's aggroing.
Is he?
Ah!
Do you have rewine?
Because I have ult.
But like, I need to make sure...
I'm not close enough.
Hold on.
I need to make sure I live first.
Okay.
Is he...
He's still aggroed to me, by the way.
He's still...
I can't use my ult when he's aggroed.
Okay, I can do it now.
I'm ready.
I used it.
I knocked him down.
Please.
He's still aggroed to me.
Really?
Is one of your weapons, things are more likely to attack you?
I'm just wondering.
I don't know.
Oh, thank god.
There's only room for one bird in this realm.
And that's right!
It's me!
I'm using a stamina, I don't care.
Rotate your ults.
Use one when the boss goes into an invuln bubble.
Oh, is this for this boss?
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, so you guys...
One of you wants to have an ult when the boss is invulnerable.
Okay, I see...
Presumably it will break the bubble.
So don't just spam your ult.
I think it's what we're trying to do.
It'll be mine, because mine's an arrow, so...
I think it'll be easier.
Okay, I'm level 11 for this boss.
So wait for the bubble to break.
Got it.
No, no, no.
He's...
They're saying, like, use your ult on the bubble to break it.
Okay.
I think.
He also says, watch your feet.
And my chat went, like, crazy once he said that, so...
Nice.
Why would that be?
All right.
I'm ready when you guys are.
I am.
It's okay, Doki.
As long as we've got you to do our tanking, we should be fine.
I am.
I'm ready.
Doki's tired.
I'm so tired.
Okay.
I think it's whoever has her ult, still.
Best tank ever.
Because, like, depends on whoever gets their ult.
Yeah, I think we just, we want to have an ult ready for when the bubble happens.
I can't believe it, guys.
Archers can become tanks, too.
Unconsensually.
I'm unconsensual tanking.
Doki playing Season of Discovery tank hunter or something.
Time for the next one.
I'm scared.
Me, too.
I've never seen this guy before.
Hey, we made it to the end, at least.
With how abruptly things kill you in this game, I'm frightened of it.
Yeah.
It's like, see, new attack, dead.
I swear.
It has to be in the coding where, like, if you have an archer, target first.
I swear to god, that has to be in the...
There's no way.
Literally, that bird never, like, looked at you guys.
Well, that does not look menacing.
Hi.
I'm scared.
Hello.
Team captain, go talk to him.
Yeah, team captain, talk to him.
What does he say?
I'm gonna back up here.
Me, too.
Don't worry.
They're like, aggro to me automatically, anyway.
Okay, maybe we'll have to talk to him.
Oh, we all have to make your choice?
Make your choice?
Oh god, no, what?
I wish to have great strength.
I wish for eventual greatness.
I want to fight at utmost strength.
I refuse to make a deal.
Oh, wait.
What?
I'm scared.
Is this, like, monkey paw situation?
Is this a monkey paw situation?
I refuse.
I don't know.
I swear to god.
Govlin.
We don't govlin deal.
Begin.
Refuse.
I feel like this is monkey paw.
I...
It feels way too ominous.
I don't know.
You could say I refuse to make a deal.
I don't want it.
And then nothing happens.
Yeah, no, I did refuse.
I didn't refuse.
I don't want that finger to curl.
Whatever.
I already went through so much.
I...
Oh, it tells me.
It tells...
Oh, shit.
Bah.
What monkey paw did you make?
I went down to levels.
I didn't.
I was...
Zen, what monkey paw did you make, Zen?
So...
What monkey paw...
Zen, what was your monkey paw?
Ow.
I could not get back in time.
Oh, no.
He's looking at me.
Oh, it's the craziness.
Oh, he's looking at me.
I knew it.
I saw him.
Oh, my God.
I'm assuming if you do eventual greatness, what happens is you like...
You are weak for a bit, and then you are strong.
Okay.
I knew it.
Oh, my God.
I could tell.
Holy shit.
No.
Don't come near me.
Please.
I can't heal.
Keep doing your job.
What does this golden stuff do, I wonder?
You got this.
I don't know.
Oh, no.
Hit him.
I don't have all.
I don't have it.
Oh, dear.
It's whoever has all first, but none of us has all.
Oh, this is bad.
I have an ult that doesn't do anything.
Oh, what does it do?
I don't know.
We seem okay.
Smile.
Well, that's worrisome.
I'm saving my ult for this one, though.
For the next one.
He's looking at me.
Do you know about madness in this game, Doki?
No.
Okay.
If it maxes out, you die.
Oh.
No.
Oh, my God.
That almost maxed out.
That was scary.
Yeah, be careful.
I have ult for the next one.
I'm very frightened.
This is like mythic blood shit.
There's nowhere safe to stand.
Oh, God.
I have ult.
I'm saving this for the next fight.
I'm saving it for the next fight.
Jesus.
Oh, I might be...
I might instant die for this one.
Okay.
That's fine.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Is that the bubble?
Oh, I'm madness.
I don't know.
Guys.
I'm not dead.
Which is cool.
Oh, we have to keep running.
Hello.
Holy.
Yeah, I know.
This one...
This one's rough.
This guy...
This guy's rough.
I can't even mark him because he's so aggressive.
Oh, I have to collect the shinies?
What do the shinies do?
Oh, hit him, hit him.
Bubble, bubble.
Is he bubble?
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I still have my ult, though.
Do you want me to save it?
Uh, yes, probably.
So, hey.
He got really angry.
He's a little pissed.
Oh, this lower...
The shinies lower madness.
Shinies lower madness.
Yes, they do.
Okay, I marked him.
Jesus Christ!
Goop, goop, goop.
Okay, we're good.
I have two flasks left.
He does a lot of close-up attacks that are area of damage.
I have one flasks left.
Coming for Doki, but...
Oh no, the circle!
The circle!
Oh, beans.
He got me the mo...
Oh, that's so unlucky.
I don't got anything.
He got me, literally.
I had the ult, too.
That's so unlucky.
I'm trying to hit Doki, but Doki is on him.
Ow.
Yeah, that's so unlucky!
Yeah, that's not good.
I was the one with the ult, too.
And he TPed to me, so I couldn't do anything.
Uh, we need to hit Doki.
It said hit the little circles when he has bubble form and you don't have ult.
Gotta figure this out.
Okay.
He's aggro to his end right now.
I got you.
Oh, never mind.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm not having...
It's not going so well.
It's not.
That was my last rune, too.
My last flas, too.
I'm like, oh my god.
This boss is hard.
Yeah, yeah.
Of course it's me!
I mean, it was okay for a little bit, and then it went very silly.
I have to use my ult, because like, if he hits me, I'm dead.
Unless you want me to save it.
Oh no.
I'm dead to madness.
This one!
Don't we just like, run backwards, maybe?
You're the only one alive.
You have to save him then, because she's one hit only.
I have no more flask.
I don't, I don't know if it's worth pressing me, but we can try.
We can give it a try.
He is using his special move.
No, he's not.
Don't worry about it.
Don't look at it.
Oh!
Don't look at it!
Oh my god!
I'm trying to ult!
I'm trying off this!
I got the ult!
You got it!
Nice!
Oh, you pissed him off, though.
You pissed him off something fierce.
Oh my god!
Everything is as it should be.
Just let me die.
I don't want to come back up.
I don't even want to get back up.
Yeah, you do, yeah, you do.
I don't want to, don't, don't bring me back up.
I don't, I don't want to, I don't want this anymore.
Be brave, dookie.
I don't want to be part of this anymore.
YouTube missed you, dookie.
No, I don't.
We'll miss you if you go.
Please, I don't want to go back.
Don't bring me back!
I told you that!
I'm stuck in an animation!
Stop!
I don't want to be back!
I gotta go hit the thing.
Hold on, Virvec.
You have to hit the runes!
Yeah, I am.
I'm hitting them.
Zed, hit the runes!
Zed's dead!
Oh no, Zed's dead?
Okay, Zed, don't hit the runes.
Whatever.
Now that it's your turn.
No, Zed, go to life!
Leave me!
I don't wanna...
The moment I come back up, he's gonna come after me.
Yeah, I only have one, Zed, so you can get me, maybe.
Hero play, Zed!
Hero play!
I believe!
Ooh!
Hit in the back.
I'm crawling away from everyone.
I believe in you.
I don't want to be a tank anymore.
Oh, here we go.
No!
That's right!
I literally just got back up.
It's not so fun, is it, guys?
Oh hell.
It's not so fun be a tank, is it?
I'm leaving very slowly.
Oh my god.
That area.
Yeah, we can.
He's out of here.
Oh, Zen's so fucking...
Oh, that's awkward.
Goodbye!
You know, we got halfway, though.
We got halfway.
That's so awkward.
Considering we had no idea what we were doing.
Yeah, that was true.
Look at all.
Look at how we walked around.
If you press Y, you'll see your footprints.
Friends, I'm pressing my...
Ah, other ability with the freaking claw.
That was...
You know, for our first time at that boss, I think we did pretty well.
50% on your...
On your...
Holy heck.
Someone said phase two was even more fucked up, too.
Oh, good.
God.
I mean, we went to the end.
So that means we don't have to wait too long, too, for the others.
I think we might have been the last one.
Oh, thank god.
We don't have to wait at all.
That's good.
That was fucked...
That was like...
That second one was actually the most fucked up run we've ever had.
For me.
That was some crazy freaking attacks.
That...
I have...
Oh my god.
I don't know why all the bosses then were so aggro to me.
I don't know why.
It was not fun.
I can finally take a pee break.
Yay!
Oh my god.
Yippee.
Oh no, I hope we aren't the only ones that wiped at him.
There's no way...
There's no way the other teams...
Were able to like...
Oh my god.
That guy was...
So bullshit.
That...
That guy...
I think...
I think it's fine.
The problem is when you like kind of...
Start...
Like...
Cascade death.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No, that's true.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Apparently there's another one...
Yes!
It's not just us!
One other team got wiped.
Thank god.
No.
Also you guys have to remember, there's some teams that fought all the bosses for this thing already.
But we didn't...
We didn't have time...
To do that.
So some teams already know like all...
That was their first time trying to...
Um...
Trying to fight that boss.
So...
Our first time seeing all the movesets.
Maybe if the...
Tank didn't die...
Oh, I'm sorry guys.
The archer tank...
Just had to die there.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Sorry guys.
Should have tanked more.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
This...
Game makes my computer run kind of warm.
I mean it is...
Like a really...
Beefy game.
It is, yeah.
Yeah.
Guys...
Just so you guys know.
Do not upgrade your...
Drivers.
For...
When this game comes out.
Do not upgrade your drivers.
Ha ha ha.
To the newest one.
Keep your...
Ha ha ha ha.
I downloaded the May 19th driver.
Do not download that driver.
Ha ha ha ha.
I'm having fun though.
It's really fun.
Holy heck.
Hello.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, Zen you have to invite me again.
Because um...
When I got kicked out of the session.
Because I DC'd that time.
Did I not invite you?
No, no.
When I crashed.
It kicked me out of the party.
Alright.
Okie doke.
Let me...
Get in.
Real quick.
I have sent the invite.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm in.
Do you know what...
Boss it is?
For the next one?
Our man.
That's freaking last boss was crazy.
Yeah.
It was.
But we're not the only ones that wiped.
Yippee.
Thank God.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, it looks like...
We hung around for quite a while.
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah.
That was a bad run for me though in general.
Zen...
Oh, that means his lime's turn.
It was a little bit cursed because you got like kicked out.
Yeah.
And had to come back and everything.
And then I...
I followed the false prophet into my death.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah, Zen...
Zen had a bad run on the first one.
I have the bad run on the second one.
So it's lime's turn.
It's lime's turn to have a bad run.
I've never had a bad run in my life.
Alright.
We're gonna have a bad run on this one.
Each of us gets one.
Ha ha ha ha.
Wait, can I actually kill these birds?
Oh, I...
I can hit them.
Or...
A good ho job though.
Good job.
Yeah.
I'm having fun.
Yeah, that guy's cool.
The one that turns into a dog.
I don't like his...
Uh...
Character ability though.
It's like, um...
Deflection based.
And I didn't really want to like...
Experiment with learning it.
In the time that we had.
So I don't...
Oh yeah, yeah.
The...
The guy...
Yeah.
That guy seems cool.
He uses a cursed sword.
He seems like he does a lot of damage too.
Mm-mm.
In general.
Man, this game is a lot of fun.
Yeah.
You just pretend it's Sekiro?
That's cool.
It is freaking intense, that is for sure.
Mm-hmm.
Guys, why would I ever...
I'm waiting...
I'm waiting for like, Nameless King to show up or some shit.
And like, trigger my PTSD.
Oh yes, and you know what?
This is our third boss.
Wait.
Did you guys refuse the offer?
Of what?
I didn't...
I didn't like, know what I was doing.
So...
And I didn't realize there was a timer on it.
So I didn't get one.
Oh, for what?
Possibly would've helped.
Doki refused, and I think you're not supposed to.
I think like, you know, if you do, you make the fight harder for yourself.
Oh!
I asked if it was a monkey paw situation.
And even Bandai was like, mm, maybe.
And I was like, okay, I'm not taking that.
He's like, mm, maybe.
Look at this guy like two-shotting bosses with his setup.
He chose the weapon and lost two levels.
Oh, nice.
Oops.
My greed.
Refusing doesn't make it harder?
Oh, thank you.
Oh, okay.
It doesn't make it harder.
There's some...
There's some very interesting stuff going on with spells.
Look at the fucking damage they do.
Oh, is one of them a sorcerer?
Wait, are they still fighting the bosses?
No, it's the highlights.
Oh, it's the highlights.
Oh.
Yeah.
We had a spellcaster, maybe.
I heard spellcasters, like, really difficult.
Because they're also, like, very squishy, too.
We know they're the speedrunners, chat.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's why.
They min-maxed that shit.
I just wanna shoot my bow.
Oh, I guess, like...
I mean, I guess, like...
Team 10 doesn't get a highlight.
Sorry.
What...
What's our highlight?
I don't know.
We haven't had one yet.
No!
It's okay.
I'm just happy about our first run.
That's what...
I peaked in my first run.
You know how people peak in high school?
I'm looking forward to getting...
Watching Doki getting chased down...
And then...
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm looking...
I'm looking forward to seeing, like, what this game...
Five bosses in a row!
...getting better at it.
Yeah, that's...
That was my highlight.
Fucking running around...
Trying to make sure I don't die.
The crazy thing is, like, when I stopped...
When I had to run around...
Stopped doing damage...
He was still chasing me...
While you guys were brawling him in the back.
That was the fucking crazy shit.
I was like, how am I still aggro to him?
But yeah, it's gonna be really fun...
To learn and get better at this game.
So you were supposed to be level 15, I guess.
We were supposed to be level 15?!
What level were you, Doki?
I was level 11!
They said level 12 was low.
I don't really know how to kill things...
Like, fast enough, then.
You mean I was not supposed to be level 11?
Who would've thought?
It doesn't help that I took a weapon...
That dropped me all the way down to 9.
I don't think we need...
I think we have 6 flasks more than enough.
I think we aim for 6 and...
Or 6 or 5.
And then we can...
Find stuff.
Oh, they're short enough now.
So enemies give more?
Yeah, we just don't know what those enemies are yet.
Yeah, we don't know the routes.
And also, it's like super RNG.
So it's like...
I guess it's like the bosses are harder.
You know, when they're marked as like really hard bosses.
But like, we have to just do really well against them.
There's no way you guys use me dying as a highlight.
The entire reel has been you getting hit by stuff.
It's kinda harsh.
Zen?
Zen being hit by stuff?
There's no way you'll put me 3 times.
I mean, we were under level and we still got 50%.
We're actually doing some really sick moves as well.
That's actually fucked up.
Like, Emily's just mostly Zen getting hit.
That's fucked.
What in the world?
Oh, you should probably ready up.
Hold on.
I need to...
I should have gave you one of the freaking captains.
Bro, your highlights were only of deaths?
Wait, really?
I was like, Bye, Zen.
Thanks for hitting us.
We didn't get highlights the first round.
And the second round was just Zen getting hit.
What?
Bro, our first round was so fucking sick!
I know.
My ult res!
Come on!
I'm literally flying across the freaking room like Spider-Man and...
No.
Let's not highlight that.
Let's get Zen when they're down.
Guys, make a clip of our...
My...
Of my cool moments.
And then we'll get more views.
Guys, please.
I need to redeem myself.
I need someone...
To redeem me.
My...
My trickshot...
Iron Eyes compilation.
Oh my god.
Because no one has this game yet.
I'll be like the only Iron Eyes montage.
Guys, make me an Iron Eyes montage before the game releases to everyone.
So I'll be the only one.
The only one.
The first montage.
The password is showing who's going to join.
Huh?
Literally.
Who's gonna join?
Yeah, they can't join.
Yeah, I know.
Like who...
Yeah, no one else has this.
No one else has this.
Yeah, that's true.
I was gonna be like...
Who can join?
No one else has the game except for the streamers.
Alright.
It's time.
I'm ready.
Oh boy.
Here we go.
Woo!
Who are we fighting?
What's the boss?
Oh, Fisher and the...
Oh, it's a dragon.
Oh, good luck everyone.
I have no idea.
It's a...
The icon's a dragon.
I wish we have the influencer build.
The streamer build.
And we leave messages around.
And then people can just kill me.
Totally.
Alright.
This time we got this.
I believe.
It's Lime's turn to suffer.
It's your turn.
Oh boy.
We're actually doing really good.
To be fair.
Yeah, make it to like...
Maybe we don't have a rough start two times in a row.
This is gonna be right where we start.
Did you see the hands?
So we should grab that and then move.
Yeah, I see hands.
Cool.
Do you see the hands below us?
Oh, we're basically dropping on the church.
We should grab that and then...
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna catch these hands.
Alright.
We just...
We need to...
Ow.
Rats.
I can get killed by a rat.
I got it.
Alright, where do we go next?
Freaking rats.
Yeah, I just don't know how we actually like...
Well, I feel like...
Up top there, there were those hands.
But I don't know if we can kill them yet.
Yeah, I don't know if they're worth much either.
Oh my god, my five's damaged.
Let's go.
I need to get closer to them.
We can check it out really quick.
Oh!
We have enough for one level.
Rats.
I'm going up.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, please.
Ho ho ho!
There he is!
I hate the big hands.
There's two of them!
Oh ho ho!
He's looking at me, guys!
Guys, that is so fucking huge.
Oh my god!
And it's...
Uh...
Business as usual.
Please.
You don't think you're gonna catch these hands.
Please, get up!
Is it trying to like, follow you off the fucking cliff?
I don't know.
Please.
Oh my god!
The other hand's here!
The...
One of the other hands are here!
I'm trying to like...
Hitbox, I have a bone to pick with you.
Okay.
I marked him.
I marked the hand.
I'm...
I can't see anything.
I...
Oh my god.
It's just hands.
There's hands everywhere.
There's hands everywhere!
It's just hands.
JK.
Oh my god!
Oh my...
I got...
I know.
I know about giving somebody a hand.
But this is ridiculous.
I'm...
I got stuck there.
I unfortunately got stuck.
I can't.
Thank you.
Got one.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
I'm just going to fall off here.
Okay.
I need to...
Oh wait.
No, Zen!
Oh no, Zen!
Wait, where are you?
That's awkward.
She...
She died.
I just heard I'm gonna fall off here and then she disappeared.
I don't know.
Do you want to move on?
We can try and kill one more hand.
They're all low.
I lost the only level I had.
Ow.
So sad.
There's two that's low.
That's why I want...
I don't feel like if we just kill one more.
Alright.
Which ones are low?
Oh my god.
I'm being thrown around by a hand.
I don't know.
I'm...
There's another giant one.
I burned him.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I got binded.
I can't help you.
He's low.
Is he low?
Oh, I...
Did fire on him?
Okay, we should go.
I don't think this is worth it.
The first one gave a lot.
I mean, we could do this one.
This big hand.
Right here.
I left.
Oh.
He said we should go.
I'm sorry.
That's fine.
We can go now.
I feel like we should just kill a boss.
I don't think it's worth that much.
Uh...
We got to...
I got to level four.
I think.
Alright.
Oops.
All hands.
I got a level four too.
There's a little...
Little building there.
Yeah.
We should get there.
We should get that.
Nice.
Yeah, let's see if we can get this little building here.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Good idea.
Yeah, it feels like there's probably a route you should go.
To get like...
Oh my fuck.
Is that boss?
To get as much, uh...
What's that?
Is that something attacking us?
Oh, I guess instead of jars is magic now?
Oh.
There's Alexander jars in here.
I'm like a little behind you guys, so...
Oh, are we in the zone?
I love them so much.
No, definitely not.
We didn't kill any bosses, so this is a little awkward though for us.
Jesus.
Oh.
Going up.
That's 2,000 points.
We...
We wanna get out, I think.
Okay, I'll come over.
I'll follow you.
I mean, we can go up, but...
We're gonna be left in the...
Out of the ring, I think.
There's nothing you hear that's not good.
I just wanna find some...
Some bosses, because we haven't...
Let's go find some more stuff.
Because we haven't done a single boss yet.
Yeah, but I'm pretty high up on levels, because those hands were worth a lot.
That's true.
Oh, there's a boss here.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait for Sen.
I want to kill them anyway.
I mean, we can start.
Okay.
I used my ult accidentally.
Oh, that's a...
Wait, hold on.
Blackblade Kindred?
Hmm.
This might be a bad idea.
Let's not...
Yeah, let's do him for now.
Okay.
We know he's there, but I think that's a fucking bad idea.
Alright, we can do that when we level up more.
But we still need...
Yeah, that's the big guy.
He's marked already, so we should be good.
We'll do him day two.
We'll go over here.
Alright.
If you guys see a grace, let me know.
I feel like we can get another level up in.
Looking for stuff.
Oh!
Alright.
I can't wait for the easiest boss in this area.
Oh, we're on face.
Nope, that's not a thing.
Gonna kill this guy.
Mark and press.
Marked.
Dead.
Okay, what else is here?
Hello, hello.
Oh, there's the boss.
There's the boss.
Oh my fuck.
Oh, that's a big guy.
He's so huge.
Whoa, there he is.
Oh, Zen.
There she goes.
I got you Zen.
I got you.
I'm just trying to kill the other worm guy for us.
Is that paralysis?
I don't remember what that one is.
Jesus.
Damn.
Oh my god.
Trying to head over to you.
He's marked now.
He should be low.
Nice.
Okay, we should have a helpline.
I can mark him.
I marked him?
Nice.
He's so low.
We should kill this guy too.
Yep.
Other guy right here.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Ironbow.
I'm gonna grab the weapon.
Weapon seems better.
Alright.
S is here?
Alright, let's go.
Oh.
Level six, almost.
Nice.
Oh.
My chat was like, oh, you know, magic arrows.
And then right underneath it was like, nice, magic damage.
The tale of two chats.
Okay.
Uh, there's a cave here.
Do you wanna try and mess with that?
And then go to the castle next?
I feel like...
But will there be bosses in a cave?
I think so.
It seems weird that there wouldn't be something in there.
You know?
Alternatively, there's a settlement right there.
It's up to you.
Uh...
I don't know.
I'm not...
I don't know, actually.
I'm just a follower.
Wait, how do we get back up?
Let's do it.
The cave is at the bottom, I think.
How do we get back up?
Oh.
Alright.
He's like, I don't know.
YOLO.
Surely there's something of worth in here, right?
These guys are easy.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna scout, see if I can find something.
Okay.
Uh...
A dude here, but not a big dude.
I'm getting the little dudes.
Yeah, there's no point really, like, going after the miners, I think, without blunt damage.
Because they are very resistant, if it's anything like the base game.
Oh, I killed him pretty fast.
Alright, then you go for it, girl.
Yeah.
Uh, there was nothing this way, I just went all the way through.
Alright, cool.
I'm just gonna go out, get out, then.
Of the mine.
Weird.
Maybe it was in the other direction.
Okie doke.
Yeah, I don't think...
Maybe it's just a shortcut.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Uh, I'm gonna mess with this settlement, I guess.
I'm heading them over.
Where do we get out?
Oh, here?
Oh, here I found it.
Should be a thing around here somewhere.
Alright.
Oh, I found some dudes.
I'm heading to...
Big dudes!
I'm heading to Lime, I'm heading to Lime.
Yeah, do that.
Ok, I have like a guy that I have to kill.
We're gonna need help, I think.
Ow.
Yeah, I bumped into a different guy.
Nice.
There you go.
If I could kill a horse?
Oh my gosh, shot him in the butt.
I'm shot him in the butt.
I'm coming over.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, I'm here, I'm here.
Where is it?
Oh, they're at the top of here.
Oh, here's one.
Ok.
What?
Oh, thanks then.
Got you.
Ok, the other two are at the top.
Ok, I'm just gonna...
This.
These guys out.
Alright, I'm with you.
This way, this way.
Gonna get him out first.
Alright, here I am.
Whoa.
I marked him first.
Holy shit.
Nice.
Last guy.
Yup, yup, yup.
We almost gonna ult this.
Fuck it.
Nice.
Heartbow great club.
Very nice.
Ooh.
I'll take...
This.
And then...
Ooh.
Sure.
Pick it up.
I just realized I didn't pick up any items.
At all.
There's a level up here.
Next to me?
Aw, that sucks.
Just pick up some items now.
Oh, thank you.
The grace.
Alright.
Okay.
We need to go in for the...
Yeah.
I'm level seven right now.
Same.
Okay, not bad.
Hey, look what I got.
Whoa!
Oh, yeah, yeah.
They like...
Auto target enemies.
Zoop, zoop, zoop, yeah.
What do these trees do?
I'm afraid to use it in case it takes me in the wrong place.
It says that you like, move, but I don't know where specifically it goes.
It says when there's a red hand over there.
Oh, it's working.
What?
Hand...
I think hand specifically means that you need like, uh...
To, um...
Hold it?
Have something held for its passive to work.
Yeah.
Oh.
Cave guys, help.
Oh, it's fast travel.
I don't know how to get down.
Oh.
It's a taxi.
Oh, I see.
Oh, hello there.
Hello.
I'll stand next to you, so if I do aggro somebody, he'll be there too.
Sounds good.
Here we go.
We can suffer together.
Okay, I can mark these guys.
Oh, never mind.
Apparently, they decided not to let me mark them.
I'll mark him, though.
Nice.
I like the last one.
Last guy is online.
And he's dead.
Oh.
What do we got?
Alright.
Oh.
Tree spirit.
God.
Oh, it's him.
Oh.
Hey, buddy.
How's it going?
I have ult.
I do.
Okay.
I just gotta get out of the way of that.
I don't...
Did I hit it?
I think so.
I marked it.
Jesus!
I have re-wind again.
Okay.
Ow.
I don't have ult, so...
It has to be Zen.
Just gonna try to...
What?
Whoa!
Hello, guys.
I don't have my ultimate, either.
Oh my god!
I didn't think he was gonna slam on me again.
I don't know what that does.
Kaboom!
Oh.
Oh, nice, nice, nice slam.
I marked it, too.
Just gonna slam on me.
I keep pressing the wrong button.
It's so tricky.
Okay.
Shit.
He's gonna be on me?
Run!
Oh, he's using Explodee.
Never mind.
Yup.
Oh, nice.
It's nice being an archer.
It's nice actually playing my class.
Feels great, guys.
I'm so happy.
Whoa.
Nice.
Hey!
I think we're doing better for a level this time around.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Attack enemies die regardless of remaining HP on...
On rare occasion.
Yeah, that's cool.
That one's good.
Sudden Endly Deaths.
Bang, that.
It might be this rare occasion for the end of us.
We should get that and then move up to, like, the castle, maybe?
Alternatively, we could run all the way around and try and get that big boss.
Yeah, good idea.
But I think I don't really want to fight the bird who scares me.
Ouch.
Alright.
Let's go.
We need to try and get at least level 13 or something.
And not be under level.
I mean, 13 is still under level, but like it's better than...
Oh god, the creepy cat!
He's gonna ground and he's gonna pound.
He's so easy.
We got this.
Jesus, I...
I'm aggroing not him for some reason.
You're not melting this.
Get his ass.
Nice.
Rip that guy.
Where's the other one?
Another one.
Yeah.
Where is he?
I don't know.
I'm gonna try the other direction.
I think he's on the other side.
Ouch.
Just kill the mini guys real quick.
Oh, he's here?
Alright.
Heading over.
Weeeee!
Here I am.
Marked him, Rez.
Rez.
Nice.
Woo!
Yeah, we needed that.
What the fuck?
There's a little underground area.
Are you...
And he still keeps going?
Do you want to get the underground stuff?
I don't know where it is.
Oh, I see it.
It's good to be an archer.
It's just loot, I'm pretty sure, down there.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
Just archer things.
Nothing down here.
Not really.
Is it still good to be an archer, Doki?
I love archer.
Oh, there's a big guy right by us.
Do we want to try him?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I fell down to the hole.
Let's do it.
Oh, it's a dragon.
Oh, no, no, no.
It's a salamander.
Yeah, I'm right behind you.
Okay.
Whoa.
I'm just gonna get rid of the little guys real quick.
Cause they're following us.
And they're throwing jars.
And I don't like that.
Please don't.
I'm running.
I'm heading over.
Is he looking at me?
I don't like how much...
Oh, no, he's not.
I have ult soon.
You can save rewind.
I have ult here.
Get him.
Ulting.
Ulted.
And I marked him too.
Oh, nice, nice.
I needed that too.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh.
What?
We're down.
Down.
Move us down.
The tail swipe got us.
Yeah.
That's...
Is that game?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Hit Lime if you can't.
I'm a shooter shooter too.
I'm a shooter too.
Alright.
Thank you.
I'm healing.
That tail swipe actually was crazy.
Uh, yeah.
That fucked me up.
I didn't expect the tail swipe to...
Why is this on the same freaking button?
This is why I don't use both weapons.
Oh heck.
Oh!
Oh, he...
He missed that one.
I'm just worried about a tail right now.
I, um...
He's doing it?
I gave you guys weak points.
Thank you.
She's so low.
He's one.
Nice.
Ooh.
Oh, I...
Wait.
Do any of you guys use slade?
Good stuff.
I have a golden blade and a...
140 attack axe.
A big blade or a small blade?
Um, blasphemous blade.
I got the blasphemous blade too.
But it's gold.
It's pretty hot.
Is it gold?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Let me see that.
You want it?
Does it do good?
Okay.
I'll grab it too.
Here you guys.
Um...
Here.
I'll...
Does anyone want it?
I dropped it.
I got one.
I have one.
I know, but Zen said...
Yeah.
Let me see that.
It's there on the floor there.
Yeah.
There's continuous HP recovery.
We should go to the castle.
I'll grab it if you don't want it so I can get the stat.
That actually might be good for me.
Yeah?
You should grab it.
And then I'll take this one.
Attack up.
I'm willing to arm it.
What is that?
What's armament?
I don't know.
I'll pick it up.
Armament is weapon.
Ah.
Yeah, but I think it's better on Zen because she's melee.
I mean Zen, do you want two?
You can power stun some maybe.
Yeah.
Let me see what you got there.
Okay.
Do you stack it though?
Is it stackable?
And then if you both have it, you can both regen.
Also, we need to level up.
If you find a great...
I need a grace to level up.
Every freaking time.
Oh my god.
Uh...
I think you should both each have one just cause like...
So it can stack.
So you can both restore HP.
I mean, if Zen's not gonna dual wield them, I will.
But if she is, I won't.
Oh, we should go down to the castle.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm heading down to the castle.
I just need one more lever for these and I can use both of them.
Okay.
Alright.
Weeeee.
Let's go get this boss then.
Alright.
We better kill this boss so I can level up.
I can ult this too.
Oh, it's the big... it's the dog.
Okay.
Easy.
I hit him.
Ow.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's on me.
I'm just a little guy.
Uh, get him out of the corridor if you can.
Come back in here.
I'm trying.
Don't let him stay in there.
How's it going?
Um, he's not coming back.
Bruh, come back.
Wait, where the fuck did he go?
He's just stuck.
Is he stuck?
Oh god.
I...
I did not want him to follow me, but he decided to.
Okay.
Bring him in.
Zen!
Bring him in!
I don't think...
I'm like...
So confused.
Okay.
Sir!
Please!
Come in!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Get up.
Okay.
Yeah!
Yeah, alright.
That guy sucked.
Oh!
Hello!
I got a good bow.
What does the blood blade do?
Does anybody need a freaking width?
No.
I'm level 10.
We need to get two more levels at least.
I'm heading up.
I guess I can use the benefit then.
Will I continue to get these swords?
Yeah, apparently I do.
Sweet!
Raises attack power.
Raises vitality.
What's...
Vitality is HP, right?
Hmm...
Okay.
Get two?
Resistance to death flight?
What's resistance to death flight?
Oh!
Which one should I get?
Two or three guys winged?
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Uh, there's some big bosses and an Estus in the fucking...
In the crater again!
I hate that crater so much!
Grab this.
Oh no!
Is that what I think it is?
Oh wait!
I'm not light...
Oh my god, I'm dumb.
I thought it was light.
Why not, was it?
I forgot to replace my...
Bow status.
We need to find one more boss.
I mean, we can go this way.
Oh god, it's that fucking griffin again.
You wanna try him?
Uh...
Where are we on the map?
Right next to him.
We could try.
Zen, where are you?
Gargoyle thing.
Oh boy.
Right above.
Yeah, we gotta like, run run if we...
After...
Ow.
I'm not doing damage.
I'm stuck on the fucking terrain!
Oh my god, I'm gonna...
I just instantly got dropped.
Uh...
I got you.
What's the thing?
Oh god!
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Holy...
Oh.
Hum...
I marked him, but...
But yeah.
I...
I have like, uh...
Ult soon.
Oh yeah.
Let's get him off that terrain.
That's gonna be awkward.
I...
The place that this guy is just sucks.
Oh.
Yeah.
Pull over here.
He...
I have ult, I have ult.
I'm using it.
It's up in the same place as usual.
I have it, yes.
I have it, I have it, I have it.
You have rewind.
Yup.
That's good.
I'm gonna mark him.
Oh my god, he bounced away from...
From mark.
I'm looking at map.
It's fast.
It's approaching fast.
We have to kill him.
Oh shit.
Nice dagger.
Oh my god, he's so close to die.
Nice.
One hit, one hit, one hit.
Yes.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god, we have to hurt her.
Good stuff.
Ugh, I did not know...
Oh my god, there's a huge...
Okay, I'm getting this though.
I don't...
I'm just not worth...
I couldn't grab the...
I couldn't check what the blade...
It's not worth dying to the zone.
Oh, I couldn't see what the blade was.
I just went for the status.
No time.
Yeah, no time.
There's no time, chat.
I didn't know what...
Are you fucking kidding?
Oh!
Don't press forward when you're in the things.
I know, I know.
It just puts you in the wall.
Me, when I don't learn my lesson.
Yeah, I didn't learn my lesson again.
I did it a bunch last night.
I didn't get to...
So...
No, neither did I.
We can do it after the boss.
I feel like we did really well for levels the first map.
And then fell behind the second map.
Um...
I feel like we could kill this boss.
And we can lead her.
Of course.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
I'll grab...
I'll try to lead her.
She's...
It's closing real fast though.
Be careful.
Guys, the circle.
I know, I'm trying to...
Yeah, the circle is a dick.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Yeah, no, we leave.
Yeah, we leave, we leave, we leave.
I don't think I can do it.
I'm too scared.
Wait, where is this?
Is it here?
Am I here?
Oh, I'm here.
I don't know, are you here?
Are any of us here?
Yeah, am I here?
Wait, no, she's coming over.
Nothing.
She's slowly coming over to me, guys.
I don't know if I can actually get her to us.
Nah, no, it's fine.
We'll do the end.
I think she might activate into this.
We don't want that, because we'll have two bosses.
Yeah, um...
It's too late.
Oh, hell.
It's too late, I already did it.
Okay, what's going on, bro?
I don't think you can do anything.
No, you're not.
Nice.
I have ult earlier to the boss, by the way.
What is going on with me?
Kaboom.
Alright, I'm gonna ult here.
Do you have rewind?
Oh, okay.
Oh, not again?
Oh, no.
The agonic version.
I don't want it.
I ult it early.
I really don't want it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Nice.
I'm on the other cavalry.
Get that motherfucker.
The Sentinels are very close.
Be careful.
Okay, I marked the cavalry guy.
One cavalry down.
See, three Sentinels on me, so I'm just gonna dodge for a while.
I'm on the first cavalry guy.
Alright, you kill that guy.
I'll just have fun with this one.
Okay, I marked him again.
Nice, we got both, we got both.
Charging coming.
Who's gonna heal for now?
Okay.
Guys, I have a broken combo and I'm so ready for this.
Nice.
That's what I like to hear.
I don't like any of this.
Holy moly.
I'm gonna mark him.
Oh, he dodged my mark.
Jesus.
The rewind!
I'm marking him?
Marked him?
Nice, nice.
Okay, I'm just gonna wait until...
Back it up, there's charging?
Yep.
He's on, they're on, they're, they're...
He's marked on Zen.
I have ult here.
Do you have rewind?
Woo!
Yes.
Okay.
Ulting?
Ult it.
Nice.
I got that.
Nice, he's one.
What's up?
Come on.
Yeah!
Easy!
Woo!
Alright.
Physical damage negation?
I'm gonna grab that.
Wait, raise resistance to all elements.
I don't know what happens there.
Do I?
Oh my god, guys.
Elements or damage negation?
I don't know what the last boss is, so...
Yeah, I don't know what it is.
I didn't get the damage negation.
Okay.
I got more glint blades.
I have two sets of glint blades that keep popping, but...
Let's see.
I think they overrate each other, but it's fine, because when one's on cooldown and the other one will just pop, I guess.
Alright, one just to be safe.
Okay.
Okay, I hit 12, which is nice.
Alright.
Then that means I'll be 12, too.
Since we are, like, dissimilar.
Yeah, I'm level 12.
How do they get to level 15?
I don't understand!
I don't know.
Yeah, they all stack, unfortunately.
Maybe I should grab another.
We don't have Bamko here to give us tips this time.
What could possibly go wrong?
I'm ready for this fight.
I have never been more ready.
Bandai's on my... in my... in my stream.
He came back.
He likes me more.
I'm so confident that I can do this.
Alright, yeah, I believe in Zen.
We have, like, a really broken setup.
Yeah.
On Zen, at least.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Zen is, like, our actual, like, DPS lineup.
She's our tank now.
They always come back.
Push that cave!
I really like using the rewind.
Like, when it lines up perfectly, things just explode.
Yeah, our combos.
The combo shit is so strong.
Especially when, like, it double staggers to a rewind.
Mm-mm.
Alright, Zen.
Carry us.
Carry I'm and I.
Gamer of the year!
I will do this.
I don't like this.
Let me just double check out my stuff here before we start.
I don't know if we're gonna be allowed to do that.
This is scary.
I accidentally used my item.
I don't know what it was.
Okay.
Good times.
I accidentally used two items.
Alright.
Let's do this.
Let's do it.
Oh my god.
Why did I get the damage elements?
He's ice!
Okay.
Who's he?
I don't know his movesets.
Shit.
Ow.
I don't know what he does.
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
That's the wrong button.
Alright, off we go.
Wow!
If you can mark his feet rather than his head, because neither Zen or I hit that most of the time.
I can't.
It's like...
It only does like...
It's uh...
What's it called?
Auto.
The markings.
There's like shit all over the floor.
How am I supposed to get in?
Help.
I see, I see.
That's fine.
Oh nice, nice, nice, nice, nice!
I can't mark him.
He has too much like...
Um...
What's it called?
See like, when I mark him, it goes straight to the head.
So I can't change it.
I don't know what he's doing when I'm leaving.
Oh ho ho!
I'm scared!
Mom, I'm scared!
He's coalescing!
That's what he's doing, he's...
Mom, I'm scared!
Oh, get behind a pillar!
Get behind a pillar!
Okay.
I think.
I'm behind this?
I'm behind something.
Yup.
Yeah, do that.
Am I safe?
I'm safe!
Oh yeah!
Good stuff.
Jindahad, I'm onto you!
Oh my gosh, he's too far for me to do any damage right now.
Uh, big ground floor.
Uh, hit.
There we go.
I'm like, way too fucking far.
Staggered?
Nice stagger, nice stagger, nice stagger.
He's down.
I have ult, I have ult!
Do you have rewind?
No, I just use it for the stagger.
Okay, it's fine.
I'll just ult this, still.
Nice, I staggered again.
Okay, I'll try and get closer.
Oh lord.
Oh my god!
That looks like an of course.
What does that do?
I don't know.
I think it's, I think it's a phase change.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
I don't know what a lot of these are.
Like, I don't know what any of these moves does.
So I'm like, scared.
Okay, we have a hunt on the ground next to him.
Wish I can like, mark him.
Actually getting up time is kind of shitty.
Oh god.
Maybe that's where Archer Man shines because he can actually get some.
It just sucks because I can't mark him at, like, mark him at a better location for you guys.
I did not mean to double heal!
Oh, that sucks!
Okay.
Oh, we have to find a pillar.
Okay, he's doing the thing.
Pillars, pillars, pillars.
Where's a pillar?
I do not see one.
Where's that pillar come from?
What is that?
I don't know what that is.
I'm just gonna leave.
Me too.
I think we would've...
Oh, we would've died if we were in there, I think.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shit!
It sucks he did that right after I popped a fire thing.
Yeah.
Oh, he's on you.
I'm gonna struggle a little bit.
I accidentally used two heals.
I'm very sad.
Oh, that's your struggle busting right now?
Yeah, my damage uptime is not great.
Don't worry, I'm not having a great time either.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I feel like my damage is so low.
It's not...
It's hard to do damage.
He's very tanky.
Yeah.
It is.
I wouldn't worry too much.
But I don't think I'm doing much damage.
Okay.
I mean, I'm doing 51 per hit.
And then he fucking leaves.
He just goes across the entire arena.
Oh, Jesus.
Fucker.
I have ult.
I'm just gonna ult this.
And then sometimes when I actually get to him...
Yeah, I got him.
I hit him.
Nice.
Sometimes when I actually do get to him, he just...
AOE's the floor.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Jesus.
Okay, what's this one?
Shit.
Uh...
He's behind me, I think.
He's over there.
Oh, he's doing that...
Oh, he's doing that freezing circle again.
We just have to run.
I'm going.
I think we make...
It's either in the center or we run far, I think.
Uh...
This isn't huge, right?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, God.
I think we're fine, we're fine.
We have to either go to the center or back there.
He's so tanky.
Oh my God, that hit me.
I marked him though, but...
Yeah.
I only have two flasks left.
Oh my God, I'm one.
I have only one flask left.
I'm stuck under his tail!
Stuck under his tail!
Oh, no!
Oh, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine!
Yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup.
Uh-oh.
He's doing something.
What's that?
Phase three?
My last flask.
Flask, flask.
No more flask for me.
Last flask for me too.
I'm doing 30 damage, by the way.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm getting his head, I'm getting his head.
If I can.
Me too.
You got him?
Nice.
I got him.
God, it's not like...
It's not.
He's doing it again!
Where is he?
Okay, what is it this time?
Oh, we're on the edge of the arena.
Okay, he's way over there.
Wait, where?
Oh, okay, we're fine.
Yeah, just stay way the fuck away.
Okay.
Guys, it's so hard to get close to him because his...
I'm an archer, so my...
It's even scarier for me to get too close.
I don't know, there's icicles all over the floor in melee.
Yeah.
He's just like very area denial in general, I think.
Like, I have to be really close to do more, but it's so difficult for this guy.
And I can't shoot the head because his head is so fucking tiny.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry, you're right!
I mean, that should be closer!
I'm sorry, sir, your head is huge!
Oh shit.
I got frostbite, I got frostbite.
But I could have ult soon.
Okay.
I've ulted in one.
One more hit.
I got ult.
I'm ulting.
I have my ultimate.
I got it!
I hit him, I hit him!
Nice ult, nice ult!
Getting out, getting out.
I shoot his legs because it's like the fattest thing I can shoot.
Oh my god, I'm one HP.
You got this, Doki.
I'm one HP.
Deal.
I don't have heals.
Watch the explosions.
I think, yep, those are gonna pop.
Alright.
Living the dream of the one HP.
That's good.
Come on.
You just be brave, Doki.
I believe in you.
The one HP dream!
I don't see what's bad and what's good.
Goodbye!
I'm coming for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna stealth so he doesn't try and hit me.
Careful, Zen.
I'll be on you for a second.
That's fine, Zen has passive heal, remember?
Passive regen?
Yep.
Wait, I'm right here.
I know, but...
No, these are dangerous.
If I touch these, I get more frostbite.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, Zen got knocked!
Zen got knocked!
It's okay.
We got it.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
I'll head over.
Find your run.
Come on.
We got this.
I'm having to back up.
It's doing an AoE.
Got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Zen up, Zen up.
Yeah, yeah, I got her, I got her.
Oh my god.
Oh, get him!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Good hit, good hit.
Rewound.
Come on, baby.
Let's go.
She's so low!
You're gonna blow up his ass!
I'm gonna shoot his legs, I'm gonna shoot his legs.
Oh, where's he going?
What's he doing?
No!
He's FISH!
He's cheesy!
Oh my god, it's me!
It's me!
Oh my god!
Why me?
Come on.
Oh!
Okay, he's back there.
Okay, now it's at live.
Thank god.
I have one more, I can ult this.
I just need to hit, like, a couple more strides.
Okay.
He needs to get closer, and I can...
Oh, I got dropped!
Oh no.
Can you tap me?
Yeah, I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm only on one.
Come on.
Yeah.
I got her, I got her, I got her, I got her.
Thank you.
Get him, Zed!
Rewinding!
Ult it, ult it!
Ult it!
Yes!
The killing flow!
Oh my god.
We got the killing flow!
Yes!
Oh my god, we did it!
Oh my god.
Yes!
Okay.
That shit was crazy.
Oh my god.
That took you with the kill steal.
I...
What can I do?
My heart.
I just have a bow!
Oh man, oh man.
My physical mark is...
That fucking tiny ass head!
Oh, you...
Oh, we unlocked, like, clothes now.
Now we can customize our clothes.
Oh.
Hello.
Nice!
Oh, nice!
Sweet!
Where the fuck is my dressing?
Oh my god.
I'm going to guess we don't show that though.
Show what?
Oh my god, we have drip now.
Look at that.
Oh, the thing.
Where's my drip?
I want my drip.
It's in their closet.
Which...
It's like the dressing room.
Which is the storage room.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, you see like the mirror thing?
Yeah, I see where I go.
I don't have money.
Benda, are you still here?
We did it!
Benda!
With some currency.
With some drip.
No.
You know, I won't tell anyone if my...
Ooh.
If I suddenly have $35,000, I won't tell anyone.
I can basically become a Bloodborne character.
Oh my god.
That's so hot.
Alright, time to save.
You get to be...
Oh my god, you can be a Bloodborne character.
Oh, I think Bandai...
A hunter is a hunter, even in a dream.
No, I don't have enough money.
He looks so cool.
Oh yeah, there's one that looks like Robin Hood.
Oh, we can showcase the thing.
Tweet.
Oh, I already went and looked.
My bad.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I saw dressing room.
Make with us there.
I'm sorry, Bandai...
That's why Bandai disappeared.
I'm sorry.
I didn't...
I was so excited.
We were just so excited.
I'm so excited.
I'm sorry.
Please.
They said we can sew.
Oh, we can?
Oh yeah, we're fine.
Yeah, we're fine.
We're so fine.
Oh, that's cool.
Yay!
I'm going back.
Wait, where's my dressing room?
Oh, it's over here.
They actually...
They went in and physically removed it real quick while we were distracted.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because we weren't supposed to show it.
Oh my god.
It's Joel.
Oh, the Revenant one.
People are going to be like, not...
The Revenant clothes, they give our shoes.
So I don't think people would like that.
Oh wait, no.
This one.
No, actually this one.
It took it.
Oh, never mind.
No, never mind.
Just covers it up more.
Holy heck.
Man.
There's still feet.
Oh, the Recluse one.
The last one looks like the...
So who survived?
Um, the Elden Ring woman.
Let me go look at the stream.
They'll be probably in highlights, I think.
Oh.
The Garden has a cool one because they changed it to a crow.
Oh, are they still...
Are people still doing it?
It looks like they're still doing it.
Not enough as the last boss we fought.
Yeah, that one was easy.
I think we're...
Super under level too.
They still have two people on it.
I think we were just...
Team Green and Team Violet still going.
We were so...
We were just really under level.
We were the second boss.
Wait, did anyone got wiped yet for the third one?
Did anyone else got wiped?
Or was it just...
Or did everyone got through?
There's two teams still fighting it.
I don't know if anybody died.
Bro, I felt like I was doing like pepper damage until the end.
Like I feel like the only da...
I knew I was doing damage because I had ult like three times.
So...
Because I can...
You can only da...
Like you only get ult when you do damage.
So like I was doing some form of damage.
This is the last round guys.
Oh shit.
That was the last one.
I had fun!
Yeah, it was.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah.
I'm looking forward to like new life-ing this a little bit.
I'm down.
If any of you guys want to play more when it launches, I'm down for more.
Hell yeah.
I'm so ready for more of this.
Yeah.
Yes, please.
Oh, green just wiped.
Not us!
It's the little things.
It wasn't us.
I don't know.
But I found that really easy.
That one was easier than the goat.
Zen out here with her double blasphemous blades that were donated by her teammates.
Okay, to be fair.
Like, oh, that's so easy.
Also like, we, we like basically warded you up, Zen.
Me and Lamu gave us, gave you both our gold weapons and roided you up to fight that guy.
Zen out here with regen fire damage, double blasphemous blades.
Oh, so easy.
And now I'm here like shooting toothpicks at the dragon.
And I'm like, pew pew, pew pew.
And then my chat was like, get closer, Doki.
I'm like, are you fucking kidding me?
Let me get closer to ice damage with no flask.
Let me, let me get closer to the dragon blowing ice on the floor with no regen.
Oh, it's gonna be a wipe.
Oh, no.
Guys, the reason you saw Zen so close to the dragon was because she had regen.
That might be a wipe.
Yeah, I was so crazy with it.
Yeah.
You can do it, Team Violet.
Oh.
I made it look so freaking easy on Gon.
Wait, no, they had a rez.
Oh, they had the free rez.
Oh, was it the...
Did they have a revenant?
No, it was the...
You can get a thing that's like, you revive once upon death.
Nice.
Yeah, that's what I had.
Clutching it, clutching it, clutching it.
This might be the one.
Come on.
Whoa.
I'm just chilling.
He can do it.
I believe.
Is it one guy left?
Oh, shit.
I forgot to pick up my meds today.
Nice.
Okay.
Is it just one guy left in that?
In the...
In the last fight?
It's...
Yeah.
No, Raiditz.
Which, which...
Oh, shit.
Raiditz is alive and is kind of like chain wiping because of how big his attacks are.
Oh.
Like once you have to stop and actually start trying to rez, it's a pain in the ass.
Oh, no.
Hit it up for day two.
No thyroxine.
That was stupid.
I was so...
I was so all consumed by doing this.
They might be able to.
Yeah.
We were so tired yesterday, guys.
We were so tired.
Some...
Like a lot of teams know what's up on the second.
Like...
What was it?
Some of the bosses.
And then...
We were just happy we beat the first boss yesterday.
Oh my god.
I like how they were like, we're done with the staring at the crawling around on the ground cam and put all three in again.
Oh my god, Lyme was off her meds.
Yeah.
It's okay.
It usually takes about seven days for them to fully like actually disappear.
So...
It's okay.
I'll just be more...
A little bit more tired.
Yeah.
Wait.
Does that mean we're going to disappear?
Oh, no.
Okay.
No, no.
When I'm off my meds, you get stronger.
When...
No, yeah.
Like when she...
She's on her meds right now, so she sees us.
When she's off her meds, we disappear.
Oh, that was such a bitch.
It was a good idea.
He tried to use his ult to res them like an AoE.
Yeah.
But then like...
Because his hitbox is so big as the dog, he just hit all the ice and immediately got kicked out of his ult.
Oh...
That sucked.
Oh, I never used my weapon art.
I didn't even realize I had one.
All three of them are off.
Four of fives and clutch.
Are they...
They could be clutching this one.
I keep forgetting I had a weapon art.
They can't go down again, though.
They are so close.
Come on, guys.
You can clutch it.
Oh, the stagger, the stagger.
Whoa.
Can I just say that the music for the final boss was so epic?
Oh, yeah.
No, the music was really cool.
I liked the music.
I'm not sure I heard it the entire time.
Like, I was so concentrated just trying to tell you what it was.
What team comp are they running?
How many?
Ouch.
Wait.
Hold up.
One hunter dude, one zen class, and one dog man.
Oh, no.
We're back to where we were.
Hunter.
Alright.
Let me check.
Guys, we're just watching the event right now.
Alright.
Oh, no.
Wait.
No, they're done.
Oh, no.
No, there's one more.
No, he's still alive.
There's still one more.
No.
Oh, am I behind?
They're done.
It was a good try.
Dude, how did they get to level 14?
How did they?
I think it's the routes.
It's rigged.
Rigged.
We just don't know our routes.
I mean, look at their routes.
It looks like they know exactly where to go.
I mean, look at their maps.
They were very confident.
Like, I was busy all day doing dog training and stuff.
And every now and again, the channel would go, can anyone do a run with me?
And I'm like, should I have done more runs?
Yeah, people were like looking for runs and stuff.
Okay, we were able to defeat the dragon guy at level 12.
That's all I'm saying.
We did it at level 12.
We did it.
And I didn't use my weapon rights once because I keep forgetting.
We actually carried like everybody asked.
Hehehehe.
The Entrea was our B-doof for the last round.
As promised.
We were like, here, have some more HMs.
Have all the rare candies.
I just unmuted to hear the words four-way tiebreaker and I kind of want to die.
Hehehehe.
Oh yeah, it's the four speedrunner slash pro player teams.
This time, they gotta get us our good side.
I don't think we were in the tiebreaker.
Did all the...
No, we didn't.
Like, good players get all three.
I think tiebreakers are whoever beat all three rounds together.
Right, right, right, right.
Yeah, okay, cool.
Oh God, we can rest.
We can rest.
Yeah.
I guess they're...
Oh, thank God, I don't have to freaking say anything.
I guess they just have to...
They have to just like...
I would be too nervous.
Oh, I guess...
What the fuck?
What does the...
I love the Falling Star Beast.
He's such a cool boss.
Oh my God, you can tell they're pros.
They look like they know what they're doing.
He really is.
Hey, I like, killed this guy when I really shouldn't have an Elden Ring.
I know all those moves.
Do you think we'll get a highlight reel that isn't just them getting exploded this time?
That would be cool.
That'd be pretty cool.
Wow, these guys look like they know what they're doing, guys.
I really would love that.
Except for him.
He died.
Yeah, Team Grey wiped there.
Team Grey?
Yeah, Team Grey just wiped.
Was Team Grey just wiped?
Oh, Team Grey wiped?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, on the...
Not on the final boss, but on the day two boss.
Wait, how is that a high...
Their highlight is a...
That's fucked up.
Their highlight was a wipe.
They're...
That's so fucked up!
Oh my god!
Yeah, I swear if we get cucked on the cool highlights again...
I can't believe it.
I'm gonna be sad.
There's so many bosses in this.
Like, watching the highlights, people are getting stuff that I've not seen at all.
Yeah.
Which is really cool.
I'm just seeing how the bow guy do it.
You're going to see me do some crazy ass moves, by the way, if they did it.
Oh, Team Blue!
Wait, Iron Eyes is meta!
Oh my god!
I played meta!
Let's go!
Dookie's playing meta cringe.
Okay, Zen's character is also meta, too.
I had fun on Dutchess, so that's what matters.
Okay.
Wait, did Team Blue?
Team Blue got through, right?
Team Blue didn't wipe, right?
I can't imagine they did.
Yeah.
They were doing very well most rounds.
Let him go!
Playing meta cringe.
Look, I chose Iron Eyes because I don't have to dodge as much, I thought.
I thought that I wouldn't have to dodge as much, but I was wrong.
I was very wrong.
I'm sad we didn't get to fight the Duke's dear Freya.
Whoa!
Giant spider.
Oh, he uses, like, his thing to dodge.
That's smart, actually.
Where is this area?
We've never been here before!
It's underground somewhere, and I don't know where.
Where is this place?
It was underground.
Yeah.
Oh, that was cool.
Wait, Dancer?
Sorry, I zoned out.
I would love to fight Dancer.
Wait, was...
Is that the guy that he was fighting just in?
Yeah, Dancer's amazing.
It's a Dark Souls 3 boss.
Oh!
I could've just shot the leg for you guys, and he'll get stacked.
Hahaha!
I could've helped a little more if I shot the leg.
Whoopsie.
Guys, I'm just watching the... Jesus, the damage that these teams do.
Yeah, these guys know what they're doing.
I wonder if they make a leaderboard, you know?
Like, you know how, like, they do, like, leaderboard for, like, runs completed and stuff?
Mm-hmm.
I wonder if they do that.
Jesus Christ, now!
Is this HP just disappeared?
Oh, did you watch the demihuman queen just explode?
Yeah.
What?
How many seconds was that?
Holy crap, dude.
Like, ten.
Bro, what the fuck?
They did so much damage in two, in three hits!
Guys, I think...
They didn't even sweat.
Bro!
Hey, look, it's us!
We're beating the hell out of that guy.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah, because, like, he marks him, and then the magic just hits the head.
I think he's dead instantly.
At least Iron Eyes is meta, guys.
At least Iron Eyes is meta.
It's us.
Nice, look at us go.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, this is us doing poke damage on the dragon.
Yay, Zen, you got to be seen doing something other than death.
Yippee!
This is me kill-stealing.
I didn't die.
Yay, kill-steal!
There's me, kill-stealing the final night lord.
Oh, shit.
Team 10 got, like, smacked down there.
Oh, dancer again.
Yeah.
Oh, they died.
Oh, they wiped there?
Yeah.
They didn't know the pillar strut.
Those guys haven't fought Jindahad.
Oh, that's what would have happened if we didn't get to a pillar.
But did this team wipe?
Yeah.
I don't think so.
I mean, they killed the boss.
Oh, they killed the boss.
Oh, yeah, they did.
Yeah, they did.
Nice.
I feel like all the speedrun team...
Look at that swag strafe.
They're like, yeah, we'll kill that guy while at the same time dealing with the circle.
Yeah, like, that's fine.
Wait, are these teammates okay?
No.
Oh, no.
Goodbye.
Wait, they can't even...
Oh, he can't...
How does...
He can't even get...
Oh, they just...
That's the highlight!
The highlight is I'm getting eaten by the ring.
Yeah.
Feels like mage is so squishy, though.
Like, look at their HP.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, it's mostly about, like...
Not getting hit.
Yeah.
Unfortunately, with your...
The boss fucking hates you passive, I'm not sure how that would work for you.
I'm just thinking, like...
Like, must be, like, mana control, too.
And everything.
Because the only way to get mana back is at the grace area.
Yeah.
I think you can get skills that give you, like, FP restored on thing.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, team green.
Oh, the ult.
That's such a good ult.
Using the ult to...
Res.
Oh, why did we never saw this guy?
The boat guy?
We just got a...
Oh, mage has passive mana.
Oh.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
They're saying, like, you just need to have two tanks to tank everything while you're on mage.
Right.
Yay.
Oh, are they saying that we can head out whenever?
All right.
I'll watch...
Yeah, I think so.
Well, we watched our highlights, so we don't have to...
We already watched our highlights.
Who cares?
GG's, guys.
I've been live for, like, eight hours.
It's 2am.
I'm heading out.
GG's.
It was amazing that we did so good.
I'm so proud of us.
GG.
Yeah, thank you so much for the invite, Zen.
You'll get some rest.
Thank you, Zen.
I had a great time.
GG's.
It was so fun.
Thank you, guys.
I guess everyone do more runs.
It's so awesome.
When the game is fully out, let me know.
I'm so down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give me a message anytime.
It'll be fun.
GG's, guys.
GG's.
Good night, friends.
It's literally coming out tomorrow, or is it the day after?
It's coming out tomorrow.
It's like tomorrow, I think.
Yeah.
Guys, it's tomorrow.
I don't know.
Chat always gives me the right information.
Chat's like my chat.
Chat's like my at grok, you know?
Like, you're like, at grok is, when is it?
And instead of at grok, I just do at chat.
Yeah, it's tomorrow.
Cool.
22 hours.
That's nice.
Yeah, GG's everyone.
Have fun.
GG.
Bye-bye, guys.
I'm so excited.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Thank you, everyone.
That was so fun.
I still can't believe Jake from Overwatch is...
Is that Jake from Overwatch?
I can't believe Jake from Overwatch is casting this.
But I hope you guys...
Oh, my God.
He always knows whenever I'm ending.
He knows, like, my ending voice.
But thank you, everybody, for coming.
Oh, his thing got cut off.
Then she left.
Then I was going to rejoin, then she left.
Um...
No.
Anyway, I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
Come on.
Upsies?
Oh, you don't like it?
You don't want it?
No, no, no, no.
Barf anymore.
Okay.
He's on my lap.
Thank you, everyone, for watching.
It was really fun.
I had a great time checking out Night Ring.
I think it's actually...
I think it's really fun.
Especially when you have a group of friends.
Um...
No, I already fed him before.
I fed him, um...
In the middle of the stream.
Um...
But...
I honestly think it's definitely really, really fun.
In my opinion.
Um...
Especially...
I think multiplayer was really fun.
I tried to do solo runs.
But it wasn't for me.
Because I feel like...
If I'm doing solo runs.
I feel like I just...
I just rather just play base game on the ring.
But the multiplayer aspect is definitely, um...
Really, really fun for me.
Um...
I guess those who want to do, like, more roguelike and stuff.
Like, if they want to do roguelike and more of a challenge.
Um...
You got...
You can try the solo run.
Um...
For, like, more of a challenge.
And for more of, like, the...
Like, the randomizer type idea.
Um...
But, like...
I know there's, like, matchmaking and stuff.
So, it's not like you need to have friends to play it.
But then, also because it's matchmaking.
Um...
You know, sometimes you might not get the best teammates.
also, You can have doubles of the same character, by the way.
We didn't show it.
Because obviously, like, why choose doubles of the same character?
When we won, like...
You know...
Like, different characters.
But you can't, like, have repeats.
So you can have, like...
you know, two archers.
Or, like, um...
Because we tried it out last...
Like, yesterday.
But...
It was really fun.
I hope you guys loved the preview of Night Reign.
I had a lot of fun playing it.
I really enjoyed Archer.
Um, Archer in it.
Triple Archers, let's go!
You know, Triple Archers means three tanks!
But I hope you guys all enjoyed the preview of Night Reign.
Um, I had a fun time playing with Zen and Laimu, um, you know, getting the experience.
Like, you know, we're all, you three of us, we're not pros, we're not speedrunners.
But I think we all three of us did really, really well and we did really good teamwork and everything.
Um, we worked together, like, you know, giving each other gear and everything.
We don't talk about round two though.
Round two, I followed up.
I... false prophet.
Um...
It wasn't my fault that I died.
I'll just say that.
Um, um, um, there was only round, there was only round one and three.
Round two, there was a gas leak.
Um, but... thank you all for coming.
Um, I'm gonna head off now.
Um, very, very busy.
Very, very busy.
Ooh, next week there might be a little special announcement!
On Twitter!
I don't, on Twitter!
So, uh, um, can't say what it is, but there might be a really special announcement on Twitter next week, maybe.
Um, um, I'm really, really excited, but it might mean I'm gonna be super duper busy.
So the reason why I can't hang out more right now after stream is because I'm very, very busy, um, next month in June.
Um, and you'll know why very soon.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
You'll know why next week.
Uh, why I'll be very, very busy in June.
Um, anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around, and get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!
Feel free to check out Lime and Zen!
Great teammates!
It was a very fun time.
They were both really, really good at Souls game.
And then I was the archer!
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Bye guys!
Bye!